hello my friends it's time again this
episode of the podcast this is July 4th
weekend so I know you're gonna be out
there at the lake or the beach taking
your clothes off trying to look sexy in
your swimsuit and it's probably a
disaster we can help you ladies and
gentlemen this episode is brought to you
by audit calm its onn IT I've always
been a big proponent of kettlebells
because it's one of the first
weightlifting things that I've ever done
that allows me to kind of get like the
whole workout in like a lot of times
when I used to lift weights where you
lift weights and then another day I'd do
cardio I do one day weights one day of
cardio but with a really good kettlebell
workout I get a brutal cardio workout
and it allows me to get it all done in
one shot I'm a huge fan of them they
just it's fun to do and it's it makes
you feel like some Russian savage living
in Siberia back in the 1930s or whatever
the fuck they invented these things what
they are is it's like a cannon ball with
a big metal handle on it and you swing
them around and in doing so and all
these various exercises you develop what
they call functional strength meaning
strength for your entire body not
isolated individual movements but your
entire body and do they have no chimp
where's the chance I'd say something's
missing
the motherfuckers ran out of champions
ran away now we must have run out those
fucking things sell like crazy
that's the primal bells the primal bells
are these new kettle bells that we had
this is the most important thing they
look cool as shit there there there we
have chimpanzees and then we also have
zombies we have apes rather we also have
zombies but the the most important thing
is that they don't just look good but
that they're 3d mapped what we have them
is we made sure that all of the
kettlebells you're getting there they're
not imbalanced like you can make a cool
face but if the cool face wasn't
balanced it would kind of defeat the
purpose of the kettlebell the whole idea
about a kettlebell is it's gotta be
balanced when you move it so it looks
badass but you get a like I use the the
gorilla and I you get a really good
workout with it it doesn't feel at all
like a gimmick even when it slams into
your arm with a gorilla face first if
you're an idiot
if you're not paying attention to how
you saw
the kettlebells one thing that I can
really not stress enough when it comes
to this stuff if you're thinking about
doing any kind of physical activity if
you've never worked out before you've
got to do two things if you can the one
thing the if you can part is hire a
personal trainer to show you how to do
the movements correctly just you know
find out there's someone will do it for
you probably let you iPhone video it and
let let someone you know show you how to
do like a clean and press how to do a
windmill how to do these things
correctly and then videotape and then
you can do it on your own and you could
literally never have to go to a gym
again with a chin up bar and a couple
kettlebells like you can get ferocious
workouts in on a daily basis but start
slow it's if you're a mean head like me
and in you're a dummy and you if the you
know someone says take three vitamins
you're like oh say fuck at five and see
what's up um you could hurt yourself
with these things start slow we have
thirty five pounders we have eighteen
pounders the howler monkey is 18 pounds
and we go all the way up to 70 pounds
with the primal bells but if you're a
real savage one of those bonafide
fitness freaks like perhaps one let's go
those CrossFit dudes who enter into
those championships
that bitch asked seventy pounds is
probably not gonna be enough for you if
that's the case we sell them even
heavier the heaviest ones we sell I
don't know why they do them in kilograms
I guess that's out of respect to Mother
Russia or some shit they all say
kilogram
I think they don't say yeah we got rid
of food but it's now it's still in
kilogram okay what the fuck is 40
kilograms let's find out what Stella
I think it's 88 pounds that they would
do that yeah what is 40 kilograms in
pound yes it's 88 pounds so that's the
heaviest one we have if you can throw
around an 88 pound kettlebell you are
some kind of man oh if everybody else
starts low be healthy and like I said
it's my favorite all-time method of just
physical exercise just you know without
martial arts being the obvious number
one but just for regular exercise
kettlebells are the shit and it feels
good it feels good when you do them it's
just it's like it's it's it's you're
stretching out a lot and
a lot of the moments so it's got almost
like a yoga sort of a vibe to it like
windmills windmills are some of my
favorite things to do super good for
your core and your back and butt again
do them slow and if you're interested in
any of the on it supplements use the
code word Rogan and you will save 10%
off any and all supplements
alright crash from the float lab is here
ladies and gentlemen so without any
further ado and no more fuckery a foot
experience ladies and gentlemen for many
of you who have heard this podcast
before you're aware of a thing that I'm
really into called the sensory
deprivation tank the semper sensory
deprivation tank was invented by a guy
named John Lilly who is a scientists and
a real freak like a guy who is just
really out there really fascinating guy
and he wrote a book that I picked it up
on I think like amazon.com like the used
books that they'll sell yeah like people
sellers individual sellers are selling
and it's the deep self and in it he
talks about the benefits of the tank it
detailed construction on how to make
your own tank he's got like diagrams in
it and just really really fascinating
guy and he was into all sorts of weird
altered states of consciousness and one
of the things that he wanted to figure
out was how to separate the body from
the senses and he came up with a bunch
of different designs there's a movie
altered states that's kind of very
loosely based on you know the idea of a
guy like him going completely haywire
and becoming like a monkey just that's
how I got into sensory deprivation tanks
I saw altered states and they were
historically fairly accurate in the
design of the tanks the initial one that
you saw in altered states showed what
Lily at first came up with which was
like a glass scuba helmet that sort of
suspended him in regular water and he
would actually poop and pee into it he
had like some crazy filtration system so
he could stay in there and
have to defecate or urinate so would go
through some system that he had created
I mean this dude was gone he was off a
d-pad I mean he's about as off the deep
as ever but his his big thing was to try
to figure out how you can get the mind
free of the influence of the body and
the best method he came up to was this
idea of the tank and he figured out
eventually to put salt water in it and
then if you put enough epson salt your
body would float and then he could
maintain the heating temperature -
essentially what's the same temperature
is the surface your skin and you
wouldn't be able to recognize where the
water was and it would give you the
sensation of complete sensory
deprivation that and he figured this out
and from that point on till like god I
don't mean I met you in what was like
how many years ago is it five or six
probably five or six years ago before
that I had that other gentleman who used
to repair tanks for Samadhi who's a
great guy yeah and he he told me about
you and the guy was fixing my Samadhi
tank my smarty tank it fucked up
something something wasn't the tank that
fucked up was the heater like it burnt
through the the lining of the waterbed
and it shorted out the whole thing was a
disaster like sometimes those heating
elements just the pop you know for
whatever reason there's they cook and it
just melted a hole through the thing so
he had to repair it he to repair the
lining and while he's repairing the
lining he goes you know there's this guy
in Venice that makes these like really
high tech tanks and he goes you should
contact him his name is crash he's kind
of an interesting guy and so I asked him
about it and he went adapt about all the
crazy shit that you had done to these
tanks and what they looked like he sent
me to your website and I saw the team
this is pre the stand up tanks they were
still like smaller like ones like
Samadhi but way better constructed you
you had figured out how to do it where
was just like this it looks like a meat
locker
I mean it's so solid and well built and
all your crazy filtration system never
and I realized that you were this one
loan dude out there who was innovating
and it's sort of forgotten business this
sort of forgotten aspect of of
modern-day understanding of the mind I
mean it's really it was ignored
somehow or another I don't know what
happened I don't know how all these
scientists and geniuses missed out on
the sensory deprivation tank promotion
they should have been talking about it
everywhere it is a mind-blowing
evolution in in meditation it's a
mind-blowing next step in meditation
where you instantaneously go if you get
good enough at it and you do it long
enough you instantaneously can go to
psychedelic states intense introspective
objective psychedelic states that are
there they change your life they
fundamentally change the way you think
about life and the fact that these
people aren't promoting this because
it's not a drug it's it's totally safe
it's totally easy to acquire it's it's
totally it ends anytime you want you
open the door to get out and it's over
there's no repercussions there's no
weirdness to it you instantaneously
drift back into normal consciousness no
one's talking about it no one was doing
and I and I found you and Brian created
this video Brian was the guy who made
that video where we went down to the
basement and a videotaped the the tank
and from from that video on we started
hearing more and more people opening up
the center's they started going crazy
they started opening up all over the
place and you continue to innovate and
you don't said a word yet by the way
well no I've years III I'm just nodding
my head I mean you're doing such a good
job at the at your appraisal the
situation that you know I don't want to
dilute it no I I just feel like I'm yeah
but really much not at all no I'm really
enjoying this because you are the guy
that six years ago whatever it was it
first understood that - not only was I
out there you know kind of standing
around by myself but you know the when
and when I found you then that really
escalated the exposure in general and
just isn't for me or it has to do with
industry overall once that you know you
became because you're you're an honest
guy and your opinion people trust it and
and when you say something then that it
has value you know there's there's other
been people to all this that whatever
you know it doesn't have that that
sincerity the the true you know from
from what you believe type thing it's a
lot of times influenced by this or that
but once you you know and you've been
like this even with the device thing was
a big thing with this in the Oh Hamilton
Morris it was great
he's credible and without you that
wouldn't happened you know it's just in
that these things help out everybody
right now because the industry deserves
a opportunity to to expand and become
available through people in general like
because it is an important thing to a
person that's in the process of
considering what it is that they're
doing with themselves which i think is
very important for people to take
responsibility for their actions and
what what what they do and what they say
because you know you you can you're free
to do that you know you're allowed to be
different you're allowed to go ahead and
say you know what i don't think this is
quite the way that i you know and that
this is becoming actually more popular
now this is like freaky people mhm that
are able to go out to oh hey maybe that
and they're going oh yeah they're doing
all kinds of weird stuff these I don't
even know what what a Pilate is it's
catching on you know they're right I
don't know it's just our neighborhood or
but it's a la but they're different yoga
spinning all these different activities
that are that people do you know a lot
of the crossover to currently is based
on these athletes yet that you have
contact with or that respect your
perspective or whatever and they show up
that guy Jeremy Stephens was here in the
other day again yeah and then I watched
him on a clip I don't know when that is
when it was this pass was that when he
great guide down fight he kicked them
and then no no that was a knockout that
he had in the previous fight man I just
saw that the other day he he he knows in
Brazil
incredible and he's such a nice guy
great guy
although scary smart too oh yeah a lot
of those guys are surprisingly nice and
surprisingly smart I think a lot of
people have these this idea about people
that are involved in combat sports that
they're mean they're assholes
quite the contrary yeah I find to be
some of the most level well-adjusted
people that come in contact with they're
not trying to prove anything because
they're already secure with who they are
and yeah they're Mardan level that's the
best way of putting it like because
you're forced to get your ego checked on
a super regular basis and when that
happens you're kind of you just have a
better view of things you know you don't
you people are constantly afraid of
losing and when you're a fighter you
losing the gym all the time and you kind
of mellow that out you get an
understanding of who you are and you and
also the blowing off of the energy in
the gym you just you feel so much better
you're more chilled you more relaxed
about stuff like a lot of people a lot
of what their stress is is that their
body's a battery their body's building
up all this energy and it never gets
exerted so you're taking in all this
food you're you're sitting in a cubicle
you're sitting in your car you're
sitting at the movies you're constantly
sitting and not do anything
you're just irritable your body's just
trying to dude you fucking move get
something going come on you've got all
this shit pent up and then someone get
in front in traffic fuck you oh yeah you
know and people wonder where that's
coming from well that's coming from you
you're all backed up you know you you
are backed up I know there's nothing
scientific whatsoever to what the
trigger is short on some of us you know
yeah pretty yeah it's also you know
you're not getting your endorphins to
kind of calm you down and I think that
the tank represents a level of that in
some way that I think that it's it's a
thing that should not just be something
that people it becomes popular but
something that becomes popular in in a
way where people get a chance to do a
new thing that they could get excited
about which is one of the things that
people like with like Pilates or yoga a
new thing they could be excited about
that could benefit them mentally which
is where I think we're missing out on a
lot of this stuff I think yoga does
benefit you mentally I think it calms
you down
and it's very good for you physically
but the physical aspect the mental
aspect coincide with the tank it's a
hundred percent mental it's a weird
weird experience plus it's available to
it for it for a human being to actually
participate in this meditation where you
set the room with your legs crossed and
you're supposed to check out somehow I
can't I can't do that but I go sit in
that box for a couple few hours and go
all kinds of different things well you
know the the meditation is possible I
know that there's people that do that
Kundalini Yoga and they have these
intense psychedelic visions and I
believe them 100% because you you you do
have endogenous chemicals that the brain
produces that can give you psychedelic
experiences like we know about
dimethyltryptamine and we know about
five methoxy dimethyltryptamine being
produced by the human body so if those
are being produced by the body this
could easily be some ancient method of
stimulating that production of releasing
some sort of a burst of that production
and so these super Kundalini masters
which seems like it would be something
you'd want to do but for whatever reason
I'm not compelled
I'm not compelled enough to learn it but
they can experience natural DMT trips at
the highest levels of their art form
which I believe I think you just got to
get really good at sitting there yeah
just get a really good at Yoga positions
you got to get really good at meditating
you got to get really good at just
getting good enough at yoga physically
that you could just sort of fall into
these forms and then when you're
following with these forms and
supporting yourself in some way by by
making your body work like that you like
heightened your expression to whatever
it is that yoga's trying to tap into and
it's very psychedelic but still not that
take it it's difficult you know for me
is I'm too too wound up I can't sit
somewhere and just sit there but but if
you tried maybe you could force yourself
yeah I would have to force me you know
it's like what do you think that would
be good for you to force yourself yeah I
don't like that I don't have the it's
just not in my ass my another way that I
operate you know what I mean I have a
operating when I'm awake I'm looking at
like even when I'm out snowboarding or
writing whatever I don't wear the ear
plug your earphones or whatever
if I'm right I need to listen to what
happening man saw like all the time so
it's a distractive in general but in
there
cuts everything off and I go straight
into my head and there's nothing else
there except for that I see what you say
to you about the physical for some folks
they just not interested in doing
anything that's really physically
strenuous I totally understand that and
that energy winds up being they
distribute that energy to their work
like you do like you're kind of just a
mad fiend with your work and your
constant improvements and innovations to
all this stuff like you know your energy
goes where your energy is probably best
suited you know it's not the same for
everybody so what I'm trying to say some
people have extra time or they're there
in the process or pursuit and they're
that's a viable method of expression
plus it's a good way to meet chicks with
nice legs that's what I think that
they're probably the most advantageous
otherwise well why they going what does
it become yoga or yes wet either and
there's our for our degrees did you go
to oh wow this is a lot of fun you're
basically having sex with a room full of
people no it's like the strangest thing
ever they see with all these things in
mind that the chamber doesn't sound so
bad you know today there's a just going
this thing and lay down there and and
all of a sudden you have the ability to
tap into yourself I like both man I
really do like doing yoga we'd like to
go pump up I'm gonna get me one of those
gorillas a couple of those yeah that I
like all what you just had to say about
that start small though yes
yeah a baby gorilla or something do you
do any exercises no nothing nope I go up
and down the stairs that works
that's something yeah and I walk and you
know that is a decision that people
don't realize like if you get to the
airport and every time there's a
stairway you force yourself to take
stairway every time there's you know
escalator you avoid that and get the
stairs that just that alone will make
your trip just slightly better yeah just
get a little blood flow in your boat I
like that circle sonic too
you ever get on yeah yeah yeah I get on
that once in a while cuz I don't like
that that doughnut top is the muffin
muffin top I don't like to have that
thing so I got it helps you lose weight
it'll get I don't do it you know too
much for my
Damocles sit-ups or something like this
to try to get that from collecting down
there but standing on that thing it kind
of helps I think at least I
psychologically believe it's something
I'm doing for exercise
what's that thing invented for Russian
cosmonauts to keep them in orbit yeah I
think that they were having issues with
muscle deterioration and atrophy or
whatever so they I guess incorporated
this system of vibration into the
strengthening of their muscles
apparently but I don't really know it
seems like well where did they take it
did they take it up in the ship with uh
yeah that's a good question stop off
somewhere at the place you don't use you
would have to have gravity to use it
right yeah is it where's it at you know
certain electricity seems like a bulky
piece to bring up with you if you're
limited amount of space I don't know
doesn't it all also seemed that you um
if you did use it up in space if it
wouldn't work yeah cuz it shoot you
right up maybe who knows you don't have
any resistance yeah you have the
gravity's like half the thing right I
think that's the principle that it's
working with oh well that would work
fine you take a chamber up there to
space don't have to use as much salt
there or something I think it feels good
that's why I like it vibrating yeah I
don't know I don't know if it's doing
anything yeah I think I feel it's like a
little body massage when I get on there
and for folks who don't know what it is
it's like some sort of a giant speaker
but it doesn't make sound it just sends
it's so weird to describe it sends like
sonic waves right yeah it moves you up
and down it's a voice coil what you like
it's like a you know speaker has a voice
coil and has a cone on it then the voice
coil moves the cone up and down that
creates a sound wave if this those have
a cone has platform so it moves you up
and down a variety of frequencies so it
kind of runs you through a pattern and
yeah
then you could dial it up and say all
right when this is supposed to do this
or that you know I thought it was gonna
be a big hit be a big hit you know cuz
it I think it has something to do that
fat ass syndrome you know are there
people they get that going on from too
much as a stopping off at the wrong
places you know and they'll say I don't
know if the turbo sonic can fix that
it's hard you know it's true it's I
think they should you know eat less of
that shit and work out a little bit but
what I do know about it is whatever it
does it feels good
you know I don't I don't know why it
feels good I'm not sure it feels like a
little on your getting vibrate or feel
like a little massage ash like oh yeah
you can believe something's happening
you know I don't know exactly what's
going on but it seems to be something
the variations too it's really cool
cycle we're gonna go really fast and
really slow so it keeps you kind of
interested in it and it's supposed to by
doing that it's supposed to be
stimulating individual glands and get
your flow going you know you're like you
were saying about that working up like
that and you got to get your body in
motion you know I think people they sit
too long on a chair all day long without
moving around I don't think it's
probably not that good yeah we've talked
about it a million times the whole thing
is just sitting in an office it's a
fucking terrible way to live your life
it's supposed to be super bad for you as
I said in an office well you know this
we only do it like three hours at a pop
and even then I get up and I'm like I
have an office I sit in my office every
day all day long then I get out of it
and go back to it you know an office
that's how you set it up I think see
this is okay to sit around here
there's a fine office sort of crisis is
that they got that they're horrible lied
and then there's this there's the
there's the rules and you got a suit on
you know you're sitting in the office
the whole thing represents a bummer do
you think you have to do that to people
to get them to work do you have to make
them wear a suit to get them to work I
mean if you if you let people wear
t-shirts and jeans and shit would they
take insurance as seriously as they do
if there were that goofy monkey suit you
know would they stick to the company
line when they're on the phone giving
those those peps peaks you wonder what's
the image they're trying to project what
is it you're trying to you know I'm a
no-nonsense guy mr. crash yeah I look at
my tie and I never swear why when I'm at
the office I'm completely appropriate
and I'm waving these guys every time
because I just don't think that that's
who I want to be doing anything with is
these characters that are not working on
their own you know there are therefore
these guys are those who are you what do
you want what's your story
well these guys are those guys you know
I mean you're working for somebody and
that's why you're showing up in a tie
and a suit or you have a bunch of people
working for you and you want to look the
role yeah I'm here to sell insurance mr.
crash I'm a no-nonsense
guy look at my cuff they're perfect you
guys do those commercials all the TV
rich person or whatever it is they're
all they get my boat
however these houses everywhere and I
got a yacht look at all mine all this
stuff I got yeah I'm living meanwhile
I'm standing here in this terrible
auditorium with a bunch of you and this
is what I'm begging for you maybe to
give me some of your money so I can
continue on with my maybe maybe not
lifestyle that you know it yes there's a
lot of those weird guys that are like
motivational speakers and they they
motivate you to come to their seminars
and they make a fuckload of money from
your from your like wait a minute you
had a boat like you're still hanging out
here at this place this is a bummer in
here I can hardly wait to leave
this is your day you know you're getting
yeah it's not the best way to live life
for me no no I'm glad someone's doing it
if I was doing it we would not have
Apple computers you would not have
Samsung phones you would not have outtie
cars you wouldn't have these things if
somebody wasn't out there busting their
ass every day in an office people like
it some people are suited for that type
of a life so maybe if we reach too many
people with this message of get your
shit together it'd be terrible for
civilization as a whole overall me this
would weaken us and like the Chinese
would take over oh this could be it's
gonna be it's like they're not serving
factor for that we're fucking it up
we're fucking it up with these goddamn
isolation tanks these medical marijuana
dispensaries oh I don't want to live our
unnatural life how you gonna continue to
build these buildings and launch these
missiles if we don't continue to live
our unnatural life the more we tune into
the natural life the more we see how
ridiculous it is when we wake up it's
coming our way I think that people are
coming around right now is happening I
think it is I think you're right
is it that if you look at it like
America is important you know even
though I don't have a flag or nothing
like that but but it it's where we live
and it's kind of like where we're from
and it's you know sort of like what
we're supposed to be you know proud
about you're supposed to say oh I'm from
here and I you know and I'm really glad
about that because where it is in the
way they are
I'm I'm PI I go along with that but it's
gotten too far now in my opinion which
is you know everybody's wrong it needs
to get tore that people actually get an
overview again where they start to
evaluate situations and then make
correct decisions based on now instead
of like these prehistoric versions of
what's got us to here need to be you
know hopefully at some point let go with
and get a new evaluation that's that's
pertains to where we're at now in the
world what can we do now to get along
with people how can we work together
this even if these military see what the
I think that they're we sell a lot of
guns in this country and in
pharmaceuticals so you say oh I don't
think we're gonna get out of the bomb
business because it's our business you
know so we have to figure out how to get
these guys working doing something good
you know so you don't like say oh all
your jobs are gone now figure out how we
could go in and do stuff together use
our money and our resources to create
situations that are beneficial for
people they're not good we're not going
to make friends by shooting at people we
all know that I mean this is you know
this is some kind of a fictitious a
concept that we can go over and make
people happy by by killing them you know
I mean well the concept of war being for
financial benefit is still pretty alien
to a lot of folks they don't believe it
they don't believe that that's why wars
or stars or money hat yeah well but all
you'd have to consider is how much
benefit there could have been done to
America if you're really a pro America
person and you really are a patriot
think about what it what a benefit it
would have been to America to take a lot
of that money that went to this crazy
war that no one believes in anymore and
try to clean up inner cities try to fix
Chicago try to fix fix the border towns
try to help Mexico how we oughta be
dangerous we have a dangerous situation
like 100 miles from us I mean what what
the fuck is that you go to what it would
how long how far is it to San Diego it's
two hours so what is that 120 miles
something like that and 240 I think is
our neighbor but how fast he's on bitch
you're not doing a hundred no wait wait
30 miles an hour my fucking retard 140
140 145 Oh
okay so seventy miles an hour for two
hours that's Mexico that's crazy it's a
two-hour drive to a third-world country
that's in turmoil and we don't do a
goddamn thing about it and we're sending
people to someplace that's so far
removed from us that just coincidentally
happens to have oil that's not why we're
here
that is not why we're here mr. crash
we're here to fix things the oil thing
is a funny one I got a mess over here we
have all these people that kill people
in New York City from Saudi Arabia but
we need to get over here and over here
do you know what I don't believe that
oil is fossil fuel they say it's from a
fossil if you know I got fossils there
rocks you know I mean there's a pressure
under the ground see also in other words
used to be the same dinosaurs out in the
middle of the ocean I don't think
there's any more I think they think it's
rotten plankton yeah up at the top of
the frozen Alps and bottom of the ocean
and over here in the desert and
everywhere at one time there was
plankton all over an hour or whatever to
make these gigantic puddles of this
stuff that we're pumping out for some
reason and then you say oh look step
back and say but what if I'm an alien
what are those guys doing down there
well you know they're they're pumping
this stuff out of there the oil they
call it and then they turn it into a
plastic material that that litters the
planet they can't get rid of it
or they take it and then they burn it
into the atmosphere and poison
themselves and then and then what they
do they spend all their money to fight
amongst each other to see who gets
control of it and you think and this
whole stuff isn't really that necessary
could be done without back to the hemp
again look at that ham plate what it has
to offer to be ass bacon well it's just
too difficult to control you know there
was a book on the process of oil being
developed that they were trying to
speculate somehow or another that it was
that it was developed through a natural
process in the earth and they were
saying that our ideas of it were
incorrect but I don't think it was
well-received I have the book I never
read it I bought it and I was like I'm
gonna read that one day and I just sat
there I never fucking read it I just
couldn't get behind it it just seemed it
seemed kind of goofy that anybody
wouldn't have figured that out by now
exactly are you going Wow
that thing about the planets to know
they're supposed to be circle eyes in
the earth what the Sun let's say the Sun
is moving right it's going this way so
now the others believe although the
planets are circling the Sun is it I
think that this makes more sense to me
and there's other you know this isn't my
thought but somebody showed date that
you know oh yeah that means say this Sun
is going this way well what makes us
think we're not in rotation in a vortex
being pulled by the Sun going somewhere
and I think we're we're on a trip man
we're going somewhere started off where
where was the Sun 100 years ago where's
it at now and then where we gonna be
later I believe the Sun is pulling us
through space and we're in well that's
not a belief that's a fact that's that's
absolutely what's happening the whole
galaxies are moving ya know this is
something that astrophysicists have
figured out a while ago so the whole
universe is kind of moving that's that
expansion thing I don't know I think
we're going are galaxies moving I think
we're going in a direction somewhere I
think that if we figured out worth the
Sun and where is it off - I think we're
behind it I think that we're following
it in this is the way the rotation I
don't know which way is up or down in
here where's the north thing that is
exactly how it's supposed to be
described I think as it goes you know
we're circling around it I think we're
going around this way I don't know I
don't know I don't understand it at all
I mean when I watched those scientific
documentaries on space it's one of the
most fascinating things ever and most
fascinating so that it's so rarely
brought up in regular conversation that
some of this money should go into like
yeah expansion of the of the reality
situation we're in here Lisa oh look we
have this and that we could think about
now get these scientistic guy tell him
to put the phone down first off put that
Sun down enough on the phone it's a
finger counter it's a designer tells you
the name of the tune that's on you know
right it's like okay it's a fund but
nobody answers it which is what really
freaks me out man I got I got a call
everybody say hey don't forget to come
down tomorrow I know I made an
appointment but I'm convinced that
you're not going to be able to remember
it so I'm calling you now to say oh hey
don't forget and then I get 20% people
answer the phone say oh yeah no problem
got it the other 80% is me leaving a
message you know which I can't stand
leaving a message but I'm thinking they
got it in their hand they've got it
right here
they got how aren't they answering the
phone it's a phone hello yeah but don't
you think it's good that there's all
these capabilities of these things have
smartphones I think it's like ever
people other people have them Bitcoin on
it you can you kid check out an email
link that somebody sends you you don't
think that's good I think it's good for
you know just you know people that want
to do that oh I think it's good I think
it's good I just think the problem is
overuse the problem is overuse of
anything though it's overuse of softball
if you just became a fucking softball
junkie and you're out there on the field
every day throwing that ball in the air
hitting them by yourself into a tree and
people like what is Tom doing can't wait
for that fucking game on Sunday Jesus
Christ Tom you got a family you know
wife I don't get home you know you're
obsessing you're freaking people out man
I think that's bad too but I think the
phone in moderation is beautiful it's
amazing how much scientific advancements
they've done on the phone in the past
how many years they put that kind of
brainpower into anything we're driving
the same car almost I guess let's got a
pretty new thing some kind of motorized
door but yeah it's pretty similar to the
cars that we had I was just talking with
a friend last night about how like the
cars of ten years ago when I was a kid
when I was in high school I was in high
school I was 14 in 1984 that's when I
was a nice or 1981 when I was in high
school and there was a 1970 Chevelle
that this kid had that was in my school
and I guess he was like maybe two years
older than me so he might have been like
16 but he had this 1970 Chevelle and
everybody was like holy shit look at
that was a classic it's a 70 Chevelle SS
SS that's 111 years old
that's only 11 years old like how was a
car 11 years old like a classic back
then but an 11 year old car today it's
like you know it's not that big of a
deal you know if you got a hold of a
would that be a 2003 a 2003 car yeah
that's like it's a modern car like what
happened had that had that have dropped
the ball something happened they might
have hit like some sort of technological
they're constantly pushing the boundary
as far as like this this speed that cars
can go and the g-forces that they can
handle and like
to get like to track times get a little
bit better every year with their sports
cars but for the average regular car
like at a certain point in time what
else can you improve you can add some
road blocks that were up there there's
people they get that road they made
those tiles that light up oh yeah yeah
the solar Road panel incredible
incredible ice to city up like Tron and
yeah off and they're collecting energy
in the car and they could that could
totally be implemented - apparently
that's completely realistic
it's crazy we're there already we just
have to get get get somebody to say you
know a hike do you know how weird
do you know weird city streets look
imagine if you lived in a time before
electricity and then someone brought you
to New York City Times Square Saturday
night and you walk it and you've seen
all these lights all this craziness and
the cars with the lights you know like
holy shit I can't believe this
that would be like a really intense sort
of a change but I wonder if it would be
as intense as all the roads being lit
all the roads being lit to us right now
that might be like we might not be able
to we might have to address the fact
that we live in the future
like if all of our fucking we might not
all collectively just go what the fuck
are we doing look what we're doing we
have solar-powered roads that's progress
oh yeah seeing that they're not breaking
down or they have alternative purposes
they're not only to drive on but they
have other information they change would
be so strange though the way would alter
our world like our vision of the world
would look totally different if Hong
Kong was lit up with those kind of I
wonder what the effect would be I feel
like it would make people more festive
it you know I feel we're I mean you're
driving out on this road already if
these cars are trying to tune yourself
out because of the it's such a tedious
process to get from point A to point B
in a car yeah it's gray and there's
other people jammed up in there and the
speeds not what you like or whatever you
know so it's kind of a the
transportation I think they got some
room to improve on that for us you know
if they if they put the phone down
yeah if they put the phone down is
helping them communicate though maybe
they can use the phone
to make the car yeah this is the
roadways these are soul roadways there's
that guys Zach he was over there the day
something we saw we looked him up to see
he said he's on the Silicon Valley show
or something so we don't see he's a
funny guy but anyway but he said I want
to see was this show Silicon guy I never
seen this just a funny show it's on HBO
I've only only watched one episode it
was really fun and we brought it up and
there he was and he's getting the car
came to pick him up he looks in there
and there's like I said oh you got in
the car there's nobody in there and he
says oh yeah I'm going to wherever it
was and then the car took off it's all
by itself driving it you know yeah well
they're gonna have that I mean they
essentially have that now the Google
cars where there are many with it and
they they haven't had any accidents they
none of the accidents that they've been
involved with the but the Google cars
fault I think a few people bumped into
him jump out in front of him or no no no
that they haven't hit anything but they
apparently have radar they can sense
when things are in front of you I mean
you've seen that on cars when you get
close to the car in front of you to make
a BP BP be like I rented a car this
weekend it does it they park themselves
now some cars yes they can parallel park
themselves yes off which yeah
redonkulous like they just decided you
motherfuckers are too stupid to do this
we have to help you excellent
this is where I want the money for my
car that I'm gonna buy to be invested in
the ability of it to then Park itself
it's you know what there's the thing
that's going on right now where people
are trying to go retro with a lot of
shit because like there's a lot of
people that like old cars now there's a
lot of people that like like refurbish
things because they don't want anything
that they don't want all of that
interference they don't want all of that
disconnect between them and an actual
machine we could work on it you but
you're a car guy you look under a car
lid now you're looking under there you
go what is under here on or is the motor
in here I don't even know what's on this
thing yet you know if you could pop the
hood of a 1970 Chevelle you guys get in
that work on you got a wrench out a
breather cap it's right there you can
grab it with your hand
there's your oil filter you can hold on
to it yeah is the dipstick you could see
how much oil is in there with a dick
well you got computers you
guy you have to have a guy yeah you have
to have and the thing compute up and go
wacky on you to that also can happen
that that happens occasionally you know
obviously there's mechanical breakdown
too but make computers can go away
that's you're a guy's guy
after you get a guy then he has to have
a guy say oh oh yeah my stuff isn't
right but on the flip side you have
navigation screens you have backup
cameras you have all this cool shit that
electronics provide - its I see both
sides of it but I I do see like the
appeal of like driving an old VW Bug
like a VW bug from like 1970 not much
horsepower or anything but man what a
what a connection you have to the road
with that piece of shit you know it's
not good at handling it doesn't have
good brakes but you know when you see
one this is like a little bitch and
driving it yeah I wish I could drive
you're participating in the project
my friend Jimmy had when we were in high
school I was a idiot I always had muscle
cars and my friend Jimmy had this VW bug
and it was like you know we like I said
this is right out of high school so I I
graduated in 85 and Jimmy was ahead of
me and so I think that it was probably
like 1986 or something along those lines
and he had this 1960-something bug or 69
bug ugly light blue you know but it was
great
there was something cool about it it was
like we had a big smile on her face we
were driving around in it you know there
was something about yeah first of all
he's like you know a pretty macho guy
and it's a construction worker he's just
really smart dude too though so he got
himself a fucking VW Bug he's like it
gets great gas mileage like the wind
would blow and the car would move like
you could feel the car moving if a good
breeze hit it like your fucking cars
moving from the wind man like what do we
do we're gonna go kart yeah they do
handle better now cars oh that's that's
the understatement of the year snowboard
rate so everything amazing cries bye
break I had to stop from like 65 to zero
like like on the freeway the other day
and it just was like that no you have
that sweet that sweet new Volkswagen
yeah that's that's like or it's perfect
I forgot you had that
perfect contrast to the Volkswagen we
were talking to me yeah because my
friend Jimmy's Volkswagen was like super
old school like that lawnmower engine a
lot more or sewing machine yeah oh yeah
you'd have to put the brakes but it was
like a really light tiny car whereas the
new one like we're saying looks like a
like a fat Porsche yeah it looks like
like some sort of a spaceship like an
Audi or something like that
ah the new VW Bug is a pretty dope look
yeah they pretty much redesigned it for
guys and I got rid of all the girl shit
in it like that the flower pots and shit
like that that used to be in the old
ones that you more ones that look like
bubbles and it's a perfect example of a
car that like shows the improvement of
today's cars because the the performance
and handling of a VW Bug is better than
like a 1970 Porsche if you got a Porsche
from 1970 those bitches had like skinny
ass steering wheels that were big like
hula hoops and you had shitty ass skinny
tires like they didn't handle that well
they just weren't that good in
comparison to like what your car could
do if you have you brought your car back
in time like when they had the 1969
Porsche and you showed them your car
they'd be fucking blowing you be like
you're a wizard from the future yeah
this is a 2014 turbo I have this car but
that doesn't it have like 250 horsepower
something yeah they just put a new
engine and I forget what it exactly the
Fast Five are like that was a big deal
like to how I mean that would be a
little bit heavier than an old Porsche
for sure but if you could get that kind
of horsepower in an old car I mean
that's ridiculous like they have these
new Mustangs the Mustang GT the new one
that's out just of just a straight
Mustang GT has like 450 fuckin
horsepower something crazy like that
there's so much to people on oh yeah but
that's like their basic car then they
have a Shelby that comes out later
that's gonna have more than 600
horsepower like that that wasn't
accessible back in 1970 a place to go
drive these things Hey look yeah we got
a place you can go drive it to get
something remotely as fast in like 1970
you had a special order shit you got to
go to a mechanic you got to find some
dude knows how to put nitrous on a car
but now you get his buy it weird that
how they allow people to have something
like that well it's just a fact
of what we're doing the facts of this
can-can continual improvement this it's
a process and it's a product of those
things it's a product of this continual
improvement it's a product of our
constant desire for new shit
we want the car that does zero to 60 in
3.4 because the car does zero to 60 in
3.6 is outdated you look at the specs oh
this car went around the Nurburgring in
7 minutes and 25 seconds people freak
out they go I can't believe that my car
does in 740 my car is a piece of shit
you're like asshole you're not going
around the Nurburgring like what are you
doing man like if you drove my friend
Jimmy's VW bug that might make you feel
better than driving some ridiculous car
that goes zero to 60 in two seconds and
corners at to G's you know it's rabid at
dog well it's a certain a certain part
of that you lose the fun there's like a
fun and driving you know there's a guy
named Dario Franchitti's I think you say
his name he's a racecar driver and he
drives his car to his fun car to drive
he's like a 1973 Porsche with like a big
engine in it he put like a more modern
engine in 1973 bores like he could get
like a Veyron or any of these like super
complicated cars they're making today
but a guy is an actual racecar driver
decided to go for like the gritty feel
of an old car combined with modern
technology he's a very smart guy you
know he's like all these zero to 60
times he goes it's yes it's importantly
your racecar driving but not for the
pleasure of driving like so that's the
guy listen to yeah I mean that's the guy
he does it for a living so if he chooses
to drive like an old car that like
really you really feel everything that's
probably the most pleasure a lot of
merit
yeah we like passed the pleasurable
point and went to some weird numb with
cars where the stealing's like this and
you don't feel any of the bumps you know
it's weird yeah it's a it's not organic
you know yes it's kind of not organic
it's not very Mumford and Sons
yeah it's not very yeah that that's the
trend today the trend today is to go
like a handmade clock you know like see
that clock it was handmade and people
like you know there's something cool
about that as opposed to like if you
lived in 1970 and you got a digital
clock you were the pimp of the year like
this guy's a digital shit yeah you go
over a dude's house and he had digital
alarm clock you like this motherfuckers
got a digital alarm clock there is a
microwave oven it like yeah yeah man I
remember going over people's houses and
they had that I was I couldn't believe I
was looking at it then they came in to
watch yeah first pin 644 is it what time
is it oh it's 760 you know and remember
the batteries were such dog shit that
you you had to press it to find the time
and then you let it go and time would go
by it didn't just stay on because it was
the batteries were dog shit back then
you know if it was gonna stay on it
would had to be like a foot yeah yeah I
mean these batteries were just dog shit
but ever thought about that yeah I mean
those were it's remember the calculator
watch mm-hmm for some reason that one
never took off it took off and it got to
a certain point people like wait wait
wait what though how often to my count
shit they got the calculator phone yeah
but that's a your phone is kind of a
computer that's a one device choice yeah
um you better off with a compass what if
you get lost all you guys a fucking time
yeah you have something that makes them
fire yeah why do you got a fucking
calculator with not that as our first
development here and that's also the
calculator watch was invented with
calculators we're only like that big
like I mean what the fuck you doing how
often is that coming up except this is
the one thing that I know people are
probably yelling at me right now except
people cheating in school I bet there
was a window I bet there was a small
window where teachers are still fucking
old people who were there they're out of
touch with modern technology in a lot of
ways so there's probably a window where
these young little rascals went in there
with their technological wizard phones
with calculators on
and they probably I remember doing that
totally doing that how long was it
before they were made illegal do you
remember I don't think they ever really
were I don't think they ever actually
caught on because you were always
allowed to use like calculators to cheat
in school there was those big TI 81
Texas Instrument ones that you had to
buy remember those huge calculators it
used to be there was a note field kind
of where you could just sit there and
write all these like rot like answers to
questions in the calculator and the
teachers never caught on for us on that
which is open up all everyone would open
up the calculators and look at our notes
on their calculator oh no that's
hilarious
so it was like like a note function on a
smartphone yeah yeah that's hilarious
but I remember calculator watches like
we had them and I don't ever remember
being told not to wear it like I don't
think the even the math teachers even
figured out well let's let's Google that
to find out cuz I would think that the
only way to get good at math if you're
gonna really get good at math is you
have to actually do it I mean yeah math
is something that's fun to do I mean I
think which is terrible you just lost
all credibility I don't like I don't
know who you are what you just like
always the same way yeah but then you
start getting into triangles and shit it
needs that well that's specialized
mathematical that's all that condition
man I care about that assets like Harry
Potter science like those guys the
quantum the quantum deep into the
quantum consciousness I like those guys
that say shit that I can't understand at
all I love when they're talking that
kind of math when they show me those
mathematical computations and you just
go what is that an alien language like
what is that I have no idea what that is
those guys fast me I mean they see that
there's a cartoon where they're all
looking at that it's a big formula on
the chalkboard or over there and they're
going ha ha ha because it's a humor
somewhere in the normal there was the
joke in the formula that a regular
persons not gonna it's not funny you
know
remember glacier I think they're called
glacier glasses they can't they were out
around the same time they were like like
circle glasses but then they had this
little leather piece that went on the
side and then like the the arms were
like made out of rubber and they're
really popular for like two years or in
the early 80s and they were like a dumb
Mistah I didn't hang out
those people look at Google calculator
watch man it's actually pretty trippy
they came out with one in 1975 man and
that nuts
calculated watch were first it were
first introduced in the 1970s and
despite enjoying a heyday during the
1980s continued to be produced the most
notable brand is Casio databank series
the watches were by Timex were also
popular there's a Wikipedia but Brian is
a Wikipedia where you could see all the
old ones there it's a trip man
it's really fascinating like I I forgot
how silly these things were look at
those we look at the one down look at
the one even further down look at that
thing how do you get your finger on one
of them but you get a little memory at
all but that is the future man if you
had one of those you could totally get
star wars chicks chicks are like really
into Star Wars they would think you were
so cool
he's got a fucking calculator on his
rest it's so future it's so space yeah
that didn't work out we didn't give a
fuck anymore
now people went back to dials you know
like if your car is fancy your car has
an old-school clock on it like if you
buy a Lexus or something like that
doesn't have like a nice clock in it
with a connection
yeah and it's to show you this is a
luxury item sir there's no digital
clocks in here sir this is a luxury item
like what do isn't it is it it just the
thing that tells the time like what the
fuck is going on here something's going
on here if you have a tick tock tick
tock tick tock it's fancy see this this
is fancy this is fancy can't hear this I
know what time we're at I don't look at
my computer go away the computer digital
numbers your exact numbers I like
looking at a quartz and water too I
don't know what's in there I got that
shit at Target still going I don't know
what it is it's just a clock but I like
looking at a clock for whatever reason
it gives me a better sense of what time
is then when I look at a number when I
look at numbers and it's totally
illogical but I
look at this number on my computer the
upper left-hand upper right-hand corner
my computer and then I look at that
that's more pleasurable to me for
whatever reason
that's an interesting evaluation I think
I have a more natural sense of we
haven't had a log thing yeah you know
the way analog is better than tape to
you listening to recordings and so forth
like that a lot of times yeah
you know it used to record and you know
analog and then when the digital came
out kinda then they what they would do
is they'll go digital analog digital and
then back to analog yeah try to mix this
stuff up to where it sounds and I fully
understand it for some folks it's the
opposite some folks they don't like that
that's not pleasing to them but they
love the numbers some I mean it's all
different it's just me personally that's
how I always feel when I I would way
rather look at like a I think clocks are
kind of cool whenever I look at a watch
part of me goes oh that's cool can watch
the other part of me instantaneously
goes it is so goddamn fascinating
there's a bunch of moving parts in there
amazing that spin and took like I'm not
a fan of expensive watches I'm not I
mean I think some of them look really
cool but it's not something that I'm
like really into because they seem to me
like peacock feathers a little bit but
what I am a fan of is the engineering
behind those watches I'm a fan of like
my watch is Donna it's it's it's just
not an expensive watch at all but it
kind of nighttime it kind of glows like
you I could see that the the hand very
clearly at nighttime that's a good track
it's a fantastic feature it doesn't
require a battery to do that either it
doesn't run on any extra you know
something like your thing you have to do
press a button or anything you could
only see it but I'm fascinated by that
I'm fascinated by the engineering
involved in it but I think for a lot of
guys they were and I'm not criticizing
they look cool as fuck but it seems very
kind of peak hockey
you know when dudes have like diamonds
all over their watch and you know
diamonds and they thing and my buddy
likes watches you just show me what cool
thirty six thousand dollars for it to
watch I was looking at going oh man you
know I met a guy that had one in Toronto
he's I think it was like more than a
hundred thousand yeah I'm trying to
remember what he owned like a company
that imports them a very very nice guy
we see he loves watches oh yeah yeah
there's people that are into collecting
watches you know they're very
matter-of-fact about their watches you
know there's
this is a Hamilton from it you know
there's a they have a it's like cars
yeah and watches are another quality you
know like a good watch you like you said
it's Swiss engineer it's uh it's a piece
of stuff that lasts yeah it's not a
piece of junk that's disposable you get
a piece of quality you know it's watch
and it's got a lot of work put into it
and it's something you have forever you
know and I like that and stuff huh
electronics probably have the the
quickest turnaround as far as like when
they kind of go on yeah like I've never
had a computer lasts more than five
years but I've had watches that last
like 20 years there I've watched this 20
years old 20 yeah
it's 20 years old people got their
grants not expensive either it's just a
regular watch and it's it's my battery
dies I just buy a new watch yeah totally
do that you could put another battery in
that one yeah every time this battery
dies a new watch is the one that did
that to us they started the the lighter
you throw it out and then they got the
shaver you throw it out then what was
the other fit pin you throw it out
remember that was all BIC started with
the throwaway stuff and then now it's
like the phone goes down you throw it
out the TV goes out you throw it out
anything goes out you throw it out I
mean yeah we should really really yeah
really that whole throwing out plastic
shit you see all the plastic that's in
the ocean and all these photographs of
these birds that have been feeding
plastics to their babies and the babies
died and you see that their bellies are
filled with plastics you know it's
fucking shit up lately is these those
facial cleaners I have the little beads
in them they're just tiny little plastic
beads I guess they're fucking up the
water and they're not biodegradable
those things the scrubs and you know
what they don't need to use those scrubs
you can use seeds there's seeds that you
can get like apricot facial scrub like
it's an apricot seed and it's just as
good and it's biodegradable like all
these little plastic things like it's
unfortunate man but a lot of that oh
those was gone for this glass is there
you know I'm ever having my calculator
watching these glasses were really
popular they're called they were called
something also like douchebag Google
glasses star star
start Stargate or something something
like that 30 maybe they have they had
leather on the glasses it's like that
and then your cars had brawls on them
it's like we had this weird leathers oh
yeah remember the bras bring that back
brother I think some people still do it
man I saw a guy with a Corvette the
other day at a bra in the Corvette I was
like wow you're rocking a bra on your
Corvette it was an old Corvette that's a
that's a can of worms you don't really
want to open up yeah you know that real
leather
I know Supra I did bra my super course
not shit yeah I think I had a bra once
but I think I got rid of it pretty
quickly I was like what is this stupid
fucking thing what am I doing here
that's what I'm saying there was a weird
time in the 80s that the leather mm-hmm
like there was no reason to have leather
on you like look this becomes a leather
on your glasses well I I guess the idea
is that you want something soft that
does that doesn't take light in from the
sides but that also fuck up your
peripheral make you very susceptible to
hooks yeah plastic covering for the
couches now that was oh that was a dream
that was a dream when people you go over
their house that was covered with clear
plastic sit that it's a grandma's house
how ridiculous is that everybody wanted
to keep things saving up for so long
that they never enjoyed them when they
had them shit wasn't disposable that's
amazing you come in there you know the
moms telling you hey you can't walk in
that room it's all this way or that you
know yeah people some people still have
towels like that you're not supposed to
use those towels
so he's get him out of here so about a
little frog that was there yeah how
could you do that you know yeah well you
guys are freaks
yeah the dispensers for freaks a doctor
you know the bathroom props in here you
know yeah they're trying to paint some
sort of craziness anyways you know the
cleaver the cleaver Jonah was miss
cleavers name I don't remember its
warden Eve it to be Ward Ward was the
debut and was it June was it June was
mrs. cleavers name wasn't she the best
Barbara Billingsley I
yeah okay June Cleaver I figured was it
I think you're right yeah remember Eddie
Haskell I remember any houses yeah it
was June Cleaver she was wonderful what
a crazy fucking show
you imagined that there's a show that
they made and it's called Leave It to
Beaver and it was an actual show and the
kid's name was beaver and what at what
point in time did they realize that that
means pussy was it like it started the
1950s right so what you know first
appearance was it was a pilot that they
made in 1957 so when did beaver become
when did it become a vagina was that the
70s you think maybe that cuz everyone
thought beaver was just like a pussy and
so they just put it together cuz he had
played it like a pussy character you
know be really well he was always
getting beat up it wasn't a savage yeah
I thought it's because of his teeth or
something I thought he had like a beaver
a facial look or something hmm maybe I
don't really
yeah I really like they named it after
this he'll think so that's the beaver
the beef where did that go I think that
was just his nickname yeah but I mean
what how did he get it what did they say
oh yeah you smell bad or what well they
lived in a time before the Internet
looks like it was a slang term from the
1910 England have you ever tried to
watch that you ever try to watch Leave
It to Beaver grew up on it look I we can
get back to isolation tank talk in a
couple of minutes we have plenty of time
there ladies and gentlemen but seeing as
how we're in the flow of this I would
like to watch a little quick Leave It to
Beaver episode just to see how
ridiculous the world was in 1957 even
the opening when they have their house
and it's always welcome I'll be honest
the Menace remember mr. Wilson yeah he
was over there and it was like Oh Jonas
you menace or whatever he said gee mr.
Wilson yes the way it lays to talk to
each other was so alien people hadn't
figured out television that that's what
they hadn't figured out how other people
were gonna perceive them there was a a
slow change where people recognized
bullshit and they were allowed to do
less and less of it and if you go back
and you watch father knows best here it
is
Oh baby I say your home yes death this
is me this home how was the movie
like didn't go to the movie you didn't
go to the movie no sir I went yesterday
when I wasn't supposed to oh is that so
yes sir
and I want to race him by school to
guarantee the other seat and I hate it
larry's and I was gonna make believe
like I want it today but I couldn't so
that's why I'm telling you what happened
well when did you decide to tell us
about it when I was welcome to bike home
from Larry's yeah dad it's too big for
him to ride hilarious you decided to
tell us the truth
of course you realize you can't keep a
bicycle you won while you were being
disobedient ah gonna have to find
something to do with the bike well yeah
dad the stick that's the kid came clean
leg keep the bike dad of the bike kind
of fucking lessons you teachers on
bullshit he didn't do anything illegal
yeah see no I came forward and told him
what the story was that's the kind of
stuff that the kids now is I'm afraid to
go tell pop because you're gonna take my
bike away see that's some 19:57 type of
psychology in 2014 I think they would
say the best way to make this go away or
to make it never happen again is it
reward him with the bike to reward him
and say look you did a good job by
telling me in the future you'd benefit
much more from just doing what I tell
you in the beginning don't be lying
bitch yeah go ride your bike and then he
thinks dad's cool not dad some dick
who's gonna take my fucking lawfully
yeah one bike yeah he won the bike I
mean I that was a bad dammit dad I
thought this was gonna be good stuff
yeah well there was good that was a
bummer man I love the word bummer that a
while yeah it is a bummer
yeah well it's you know it's 1957 logic
they just weren't that good at TV yeah
they didn't understand they didn't
understand how it was coming off to
other people like we just watched that
it looks so ridiculous right yeah but
it's it's indicative of this thing that
I think we're experiencing this thing
that everything is constantly improving
and one of the best ways to see that
like you know if you wanted to determine
the age of a tree you would chop the
tree down and look at the rings of the
tree I think if you wanted to determine
the progress of our culture in terms of
like the rings on a tree like in that
sort of a way there's no better way to
do it than to go back and look at the
sections of our media go back and look
at like the Six Million Dollar Man you
know go back and look at the fall guy go
back and look at you know the Incredible
Hulk go back and look at you know the
evolution of TV yeah
Dallas you know watch old television
watch The Dukes of Hazzard watch old
television shows and then go back to
Leave It to Beaver go back to this shit
go back to this craziness that we're
watching and then realize like whoa
there's like this weird steady
progression up to x-files and then you
know game of throttling the media has
improved like it's a totally different
organism the type of shows you see if
you watch a modern-day episode of Game
of Thrones there's not a film that was
made in the 1960s that could compare to
that I don't get
I think Stanley Kubrick was a genius I
think 2001 Space Odyssey was a marvel of
cinema for the time but it can't fuck
with what they have now on TV HBO Game
of Thrones is one of the best movies of
all time and it's like ten hours every
season it's madness seven billion it was
a four million what's the cost on that
how do we know it's Gawker episode it's
perfect
it's fucking it's a perfect show and my
point being if you try to compare Game
of Thrones to father knows best it's
insane it's hard to believe it these are
made for the same organism and yet it
occupied the same amount of time of a
person's interest yes
so there's look how hard it's gotten to
hold somebody's interest now I don't
think it's that I don't think it's a
continual improvement of in the
understanding of human beings and I
think it takes something really intense
to rattle us now it takes like a true
detective it takes like it's you can't
just have a normal relationship like
Bridges of Madison County get the fuck
out of here Clint what are you doing
like what you're doing you're hanging
out with this chick
you guys are drama queens you know you
don't have much time left white crying
get out of there
have a drink get out of here yeah
nothing
meanwhile you watch Game of Thrones
there's fucking dragons okay
there's these White Walkers people are
sword fighting in the middle of the
night love this White Walkers
oh it's mad the fucking how about the
Giants guys are great it's a madness
show I love crazy shit is happening and
racy stuff what the humans do to each
other is so shocking and you'd watch if
you tried to watch a magnum p.i after
that you'd be like come on man
it's the world has changed we've gotten
a much deeper understanding of what
really freaks people out and we require
that to get freaked out
today's trolls today's YouTube trolls
could start wars in the 1940s if you can
send those guys back in time like the
really sophisticated trolls the ones
where you read their Twitter account you
could barely even tell if they're
trolling they're just so and then you
watch like some of the arguments they
get into what's all this guy's an artist
I don't know what that is trolling is
say if somebody wanted to reach out I
just probably not tell you the trolls
get mad like the fuck we got a fresh one
call me out it's not a call you out
thing they would contact you in some
sort of a way either insulting you and
trying to get you to respond to them or
mockingly in love with you
to try to get you to respond to them and
then turn on you they would try to
pretend that they were outraged about
certain specific issues just to get a
rise out of you try to engage you and
just and as a game there's people now
that HAP there's a group of folks said
yeah yeah that kind of stuff it's a
sport that's a sport huh it is kind of a
sport you know if you can get a good one
on the line you know
oh my I've been gotten on the line
before me hilarious
do they got you yeah I can read I've
gotten arguments with people before and
you realize like what am i I don't even
know you and you it takes a lot of time
to realize that because the Internet is
a new thing in the interacting with
people on the Internet is what's been
around 10 years if I study your buttons
to say something like that you see what
he does when you say that the longest
people were interacting on the internet
like this like in this sort of like
instantaneous like Twitter type comments
or YouTube type comments
that's never it hasn't been more than a
decade this is a new thing there's a new
thing for people so people who are who
like to get rise out of people if you
can't do it at work especially if you're
stuck at a job that sucks and you have
no outlines of expression of the evil
inside you I wonder why doesn't people
watch these videos and then say that
like with Hamilton they watch that video
there and then they're comics I don't
Hamilton Morris yeah
Hamilton Morris we owe him an apology I
mean when that podcast was made we both
got way too high
Brian and I got him we took him to the
center of the earth we just watch event
this morning we took him to Mordor we
had this weed that was grown on Pluto
and came over here in a time capsule I
don't know where we got that shit from
whose was that I don't remember well you
didn't have to twist his arm well the
thing is we're there with Hamilton
Morris who is the psychedelic rock so we
went to the bottom of the swimming pool
and fucking set up a picnic table I mean
we went deep
it was rough man I don't know what the
fuck you're talking about half the time
we were in a conversation we were like
seven eight hits and of some insane
sativa there was no way we should have
been having a conversation in a podcast
no way we were just we were way too
barbecued I turned out okay
it was not bad no we arrived him and the
tank was better but the comments were
evil well you know even on some of these
other ones you read and they say oh you
know this or that or this guy they're
trying to make an assumption you know an
evaluation about somebody they don't
know anything about and the fact that
you just spent your time over viewing
what it is they just did and now you're
gonna be mean-spirited about it right
why don't you just don't do it just
don't look just yeah you know but you
find that I didn't know these are these
kind of cats that that's what they're up
to these trolls that they they enjoy
making uh you know getting a rise out of
people which is a bummer when you don't
have a lot of time to get it because
you're trying to get through life
without as little of these you know
infractions as possible so you could
keep your mind in a positive you know
format and then somebody say something
mean
ugly about you and you're reading it
you're going oh and I wish that that
didn't get said about me you know right
I think there's a benefit to it though I
think there's a benefit to interacting
with negative people is that you
understand that there are negative
people out there because if you if you
don't interact with them on a regular
basis I don't think you'll appreciate
the positive people as much I think
that's just the weird aspect of human
beings we get accustomed to whatever we
get accustomed to all sorts of things it
seems unacceptable like if you look at
the things and customs that people carry
on in other countries there's certain
rites of passage for manhood that if you
tried to implement today in the United
States like the weird shit that they do
in Africa where they're circumcising
each other with sharp sticks and they
have to go crawl through thorn bushes
naked like there's a bunch of crazy shit
they make these guys do and if you try
to implement that stuff in America today
we would laugh at you but to them like
this is how they've done it this is how
they've done it for a long time and
people get used to all sorts of weird
shit so they I think a lot of people
have gotten used to something that just
it rages against their sensibilities and
it rages against their body rages
against their sensibilities because
they've somehow or another committed
themselves to a safe job that is not
inspiring and they think that maybe if
they just waited a little while or
thought about it better they could have
eventually figured out how to do what
they actually want to do and when you
run into someone who who has done that
then you see the benefit of it and it
fucks with people's heads you know and I
think there's a lot of people that live
a life of regret and bitter super
unfortunate you know and I think the way
our society is structured currently I
don't I don't see that changing anytime
soon
mmm it just seems like so many people
are rushing out to enter into the
workforce because the economy is not so
good so everybody's scrapping for jobs
and they're willing to take jobs they
might not have ordinary ordinarily taken
because they want the security of it
it's a very trying time for a lot of
people but if you could figure out a way
to separate on your own or you know
selling coffee mugs or fucking figuring
something out
damn you'll be so much better off well
it allows you to be
more independent in your ability to
provide for yourself if you could figure
out something you can do
what I find be a little bit discouraging
is the the lack of interest in
manufacturing products and then see a we
like this country used to be like they
really have a lot of pride and
craftsmanship see we still have a talent
pool here we've got a lot of creative
people we have a lot of you know
intelligent people and we need to pool
these people together and get back into
manufacturing our own products here whoo
yeah that's what I believe would be a
good thing get kids they took auto shop
out of the school I think I don't think
they do the welding anymore in school
woodshop I don't know what they do in
school a lot of schools don't allows
don't have that anymore there's a lot of
liability issues those things too
I don't think it's very common no not
something they teach kids how to use a
hammer mm-hmm you know you go to school
you should teach a kid how to work a
hammer a saw well I think you know
there's this ebony and that people some
some folks kind of like bouncing back
the other way and looking towards
mechanical things and being in love with
mechanical things I think that also is
going to be said about working for big
companies but I think that a lot of
these people are going to get this
feeling of you know like man I'm just
lost in the sea of people whereas I can
make kitchen knives I can make hand made
kitchen knives in my garage over the
weekend start selling them and then one
day or another eventually break through
I got a website from Squarespace and I
put together this fucking knife
collection and now I'm selling them
online and now I'm independent and this
I got kids using I'm on TV yeah I def
luigi's endorsed my my now you don't
want that shit you want some hand mage
like there's a company there's a couple
companies that have sent me crest trail
knives kestrel knives and vehement
knives and there are companies that did
the exact same thing they just started
making knives and start selling them
they were into knives they loved the
beauty of the construction of the knives
the Emmett knife they made me this
fucking big crazy cool thing that's
going all the handles all handmade and
when you know you see that someone can
make a living doing that and like you
mean you're chopping onions with
something like that are you doing
something Oh kitchen or your you know
using
for camping or hunting or something like
that it's like you're feeling like you
have a piece of craftsmanship with you
awesome what is that is it like a
connection to the person who made it
right yeah I got more obvious connection
absolutely I give you had a hand made
like my friend already went to China get
a handmade suit yeah fucking hand me
it's perfect yeah that's me and a guy
mine you know like that's there's
something extra jazzy about the fact
that you know that a guy made this for
you like that feels good that's right it
took your your proportions into
consideration yeah you're six feet tall
does it mean that your knees are bending
here or your stride is this or that n is
he's an artisan I mean he's an artisan
he creates a beautiful suit it's a work
of art it's a pleasure out of that so
that's back to that that that feeling of
accomplishment what you could feel like
by making stuff there's a look at what I
feel good about that like that what we
do with the Chamber's we we really put a
lot of effort into the the manufacturing
of them and the products that we use the
parts all of them not that there's
anything wrong with you know whatever we
use no cheap parts there yeah nothing
made in China not that there's anything
wrong with made in China but we don't
buy anything that's used in China for
our stuff at all it's all either made
here or north and North America
somewhere too - we have a few European
parts from German and Switzerland but
the rest of its all made here in America
because of the quality we insist upon
getting the best pieces now it was the
guy you spoke about Lily John Lilly they
didn't invented these chambers in the
beginning he his Doc Orton was the
doctrine or whatever this is a his his
perspective was that it was always
better to buy or to you implement or use
it the better quality piece of equipment
than to create this what it is that it
is and that is you know so I agree with
that so much then the better it is the
better it is this saying all you can get
away with it all we could do it this way
it's cheaper or you know second you know
it's I find it if you could figure out
the best way to do things that's the way
to do it first class you got first class
or no class you know what I mean these
people come up with this thing oh it's
this way I used to mix sound right on
the
monitors mix those from the stage
another system was it's okay pretty good
I said no not we don't do pretty good we
don't do okay we get it's just the way
you want I'm gonna have that in a second
for you you just communicate with me and
we'll have it just exactly the way you
want that not a problem right well
that's like many aspects of life there's
some people that are happily half-assing
things yeah just happily off getting to
the end of the day and it's slunk over
you know slumped over and just tired and
and then there's other folks that like
you who were fucking crazy figure out a
way to invest an incredible amount of
time to try to renovate and reinvigorate
this this business that had kind of been
forgotten about I mean when you came
along there was like Sumati tanks and
then there was a couple other ones you
could kind of find online you know that
were made in Europe Europe it cut it had
it had a little bit more popularity that
Pathfinder mm-hmm and then they had was
Oasis has been around since from the
beginning why was it more popular in
Europe than it was in America you know
yes you know they were you know I really
don't know to be honest with you still
wasn't popular it's still way more
popular
even now overseas like I get letters all
the time from there's a new place it
opened up in London I believe this one
in Manchester there opened up and I get
yeah messages from those guys all the
time so I know it's there opening up new
ones
you know it's not like it's already
there and established well that's what
we were talking about earlier a little
bit you know in a way over here we had a
chance to have a little brief discussion
about the you know the future in the
industry there I got a chance to show
you some of these rules and regulations
now that have been you know pinned up by
you know the various health agencies and
NSF national sanitization Foundation and
we'll just explain that to people
there's there's home tanks and then
there's commercial tanks and you know
people always when I tell them they
should go to the float lab getting a
tank they go wait a minute somebody been
in that tank before me that is a very
good question and that is a question
that up until now hasn't been like
completely thoroughly examine
and your tanks like when people come
over my house one of the things they
always look at it's like the back of the
tank where all the equipment is set up
and they go what the fuck is all that
and I go well that one does ozone these
ones are filters and like is that
overkill I'm like I don't know what
overkill is I don't know I'm not I'm not
at all I know is that tank is awesome
crash makes the best tanks if he says it
should be like this then it probably
should be like this but when you talk to
people that have other tanks they go to
die got like a little fucking spa pump I
get a little spa pump that's about the
size of a basketball and that's it and
you got like a JPL fucking set up back
there with digital this and fucking just
keep strobe or no more complicated as we
get more and more involved with the
authorities like UL yes and UL is what
underwriters laboratory they do all
electrical certification for any kind of
stuff like this these people that you
know what had happened to mine where
mine shorted out is fairly common I
showed you the email - about this and
none of these electrical issues there's
you got an email without naming anybody
there was another manufacturer that
makes pods and his pod melted it into
oblivion yeah he you know made some sort
of a thing and it just golf it fucking
fell apart
there's awesome ones out there but we
don't want to throw slinky out or
anything but for home use it's a
different thing and a lot of these
people are taking these home use ones
and they're using them for these
commercial places and all these
different people are going in there and
who knows if they're jerking off some of
them probably let's be honest and
where's that going you know it's like
how are you going through your little
spa filter that's not enough for me man
yeah there's a video this is the video
that Brian made yeah it was all shit
that I've already said before I mean
earlier in this podcast
it sounds so different that was before I
got my nose fixed wine
face is floating above the water but
your ears are such we already said all
this stuff but you can watch the video
and you can kind of see it yeah my nose
um when I got my nose opened up changed
my voice but that's crazy I can breathe
out of my nose now yay for all my life
dude I had no nose my nose I was a
useless piece of shit it was this bad
cartilage and scar tissue in there but
now now I can smell when Brian's been
smoking cigarettes too motherfucker so
that is that's the tank from what is
that video from Brian it's been awhile
2009 maybe is it really that reason I
think but more than that maybe I don't
know if I said this was tank number one
yeah that's how it's facing yeah this is
another see we're like 12 steps from
that you know uh you know Joe it's uh we
wanted to get over and switch it out for
him because he deserves to have a more
updated version yes he was okay with
everything but well crash against the
okay is that good you know I don't a lot
of here okay oh that's not okay with me
even if it's okay with you still not
okay with me and so that we were so
happy to be able to you know get you up
to speed
we still have some steps to go for you
though to we'd like to uh what are the
steps well you know this is the previous
version now of what we have you know so
as time goes by well the one I have now
is even bigger than the one that's in
that video the one I have Oh God is this
weird fucking meat locker beautiful
we're working on seven feet tall and
it's insulting that it means more than
seven feet tall
and I don't know how many feet wide six
seven and eight I think is what it is
and that's a that's a great chamber
there it's uh are using it see people
that's the first thing that it you know
it oh you know I joined the gym you know
what was that you got to go to the gym
you know I didn't mean yes you get out
membership sometimes let's sit in their
house and they don't use it you know
people need yeah this it's it's hard but
people need something to like jolt them
out of their normal everyday routine
they need something to joke
to get in they'll try one day like today
I'm gonna go to the gym and they work
out in the next day it's like that
fuckit they just for whatever reason it
didn't catch fire but they want to
improve you know and that's the first
step but the the actually doing things
people a lot of folks they discuss a lot
of stuff they read about other people
yep all these things and instead of like
actually sit down and say okay what can
I actually do today to get to make me do
something that is of a value you know
rather than you know these are the
criticizing of other people is really a
you know yeah it doesn't really help so
much you know and well it's fun though
it's fun I'd love to do it you know
criticizing whether people's oftentimes
a good sense of a source of entertaining
it's an output to you say alright man I
can't you know but you have to be
careful of criticizing too much or
getting only into the vein of criticism
like consistently constantly like people
that are smart can oftentimes make poor
choices or dumb choices and I think one
of the the dumb choices that a lot of
smart people make is to like
consistently and constantly look for the
negative and things consistently and
constantly there's a lot of things you
can focus on the negatives of things
they're always going to exist you're not
stupid
you see them but to constantly and
consistently like only rally against
dumb things in pop culture over and over
again there's certain important time I
have to go listen what you know we see
it we see it - like what are you just
angry about it like that doesn't that
doesn't help anybody like what is it
either either be funny or shut the fuck
up cuz we see it's dumb - and it's not
you know the funny part is best if
someone instead Joe sort of added you
know to the good part of our culture you
know added you know may come up with
something that's entertaining come up
with something that taps into what
people would like to be getting here
there's more on this one if that one's
empty
I'm alright I don't know either way
welcome I think one of the things that
the tank provides is this sort of
introspective moment that I think a lot
of folks are missing you know and
sometimes people get caught in patterns
and you can get caught up in a pattern
of negativity you can get caught up in a
pattern of depression you can get caught
up in a pattern of regret you can get
caught up in a pattern of
friendships of kindness you can get
caught up in a pattern of affection you
can you can get into good patterns too
you just have to reject the bad ones
when they come along don't indulge and
be ready for those yeah just make sure
that nuts with a cheeky self-aware yeah
go in there and you got to look at
yourself I when I first started doing it
I got it I didn't even know what it was
or whatever but I've been for an hour
every day I would go in there and just
beat myself up because I was a damaged
goods you know no way Oh crash I'm not
buying it yes once upon a time on sir
well I would anyway yeah but getting in
there every day for me for one hour in
the beginning I see I didn't even know
what it was but I knew that that's what
I was a foot so I'm in there and I'd
like to beat myself up I'd come out of
there I'd be like beaten up and I'd get
out no you go wow I feel pretty good I
could sit down and just have a PA out
there at that it wasn't a ranch I had a
rental and a big screen and everything
and I but I would come in there and I
always need people around me and
stimulation and stuff but I get out of
that chamber I come in all by myself
and sit down and not turn nothing on and
just sit there and feel actually relaxed
without use of drugs you know yeah I'm
reliant on you know certain things in
the past it was you know but the chamber
now it was able to affect the way I felt
mhm as a matter of factly without the
use of any kind of additives and when I
learned about that that's quite that's
quite impressive
that what a game-changer you know you
now have a window into yourself you can
now go in and look at you and see what
that is and then say hey whoo look at
that what that is over same thing
because you're aware of what you are and
who you are what you did and where
you've been and whatnot like that but
you have to be willing to you know admit
to all that surrender whatever and then
pick yourself up and start to use what
it is that you're able to figure out
about what to do from here exactly
and and stand by it and then compromise
and the tank tells you that but give me
the experience sort of introduces you to
yourself yeah and there you are in this
box and
you realize there's two parts of me
there's this thing inside of me that
that apparently has better information
and then there's this thing outside they
wanted to get high or goes to go to see
chicks or do whatever you going to want
to do is go out and blah blah blah you
eat too much people do different things
you know in the gamble gambling this is
all kinds of all considerate and we get
a hit from that you know that you know
in it that but the effect that these
things have see what they do is you also
they'll alter your perspective of
yourself sometimes you have these they
certainly see how people are drunk and
they're all like you know and they're
really you know it kind of gives them an
impression that they're more happy to be
around or something right yeah the
drunker they get the stupider they seem
to be mmm but they don't seem to
evaluate themselves from that
perspective they think they're more fun
or something yeah self evaluation is one
of the hardest things to do right it's
one of the hardest things for a person
to do to step away from there
whatever inaccuracies they've been
telling themselves to make themselves
feel better about their life or their
situation and then to force yourself to
go you know this is this is not right
this is this society has an influence on
you as well you because you don't want
to look to like you're saying you know I
can remember certainly I wanna get into
this and start talking about certain
things and if people go oh you know I
don't want to talk about that or ever
say that so you got to have a it's good
to work on yourself this I'm big on the
selfish ISM I think what do you what are
you saying though about people not want
you to talk about certain things like
what kind of things well uh conspiracy
theories yeah stuff like that you know
it's kind of a negative thing because
when I was you know in Vegas the same
place mm-hmm and the guy loading the
show and right and their truck driver
goes oh there's the Kim Plains I go what
he goes Hey look at that
and I go oh my I couldn't believe it
there's her plane spraying this mango
unbelievable so I was damaged goods from
that that messed me up for years and he
said he quit telling people about it
because they're on the he's driving a
truck illegal oh yeah I take another hit
on the crack pipe meanwhile there it is
right in front of you yeah he should
stop telling people about it and you
should just go on google and find out
what it actually and there was nothing
this is like 15 years ago
well it's not chemtrails see this is
where people are really confused it's
just airplanes create artificial clouds
and hazy environments if an airplane is
going through the atmosphere and there's
a certain amount of condensation it
creates an artificial cloud it just does
the jet engine you mean you should look
into this more than anybody because
you've talked to me about this before
and I know that you probably have these
ideas in your head about the government
spraying things in the sky I'm sure
whoever it is airplanes someone may have
done that at some point in time most
likely has done that at some point time
but that's not what you're saying when
you're seeing those clouds that go
across those are actual clouds they're
clouds that be made by jet engines like
this has all been proven this is all
scientific that everyone agrees on it
it's not there's no controversy about
this at all when it comes to people who
understand jet propellant engines or jet
engines and airplanes and airplanes and
atmospheric conditions like there's been
articles about this since the 1980s I
mean this all it is is when in in 2001
when September 11th happened there was
an article that was on cnn.com like a
couple of days afterwards that was
talking about the changes in the
temperature because there weren't the
artificial clouds that were used to
having overhead on a daily basis that
are created when planes fly through the
atmosphere so it's not something that
they were being like secretive about
this is just an effect of airplanes the
real chemtrails one of the things that I
said on my television show when we
covered this burning jet fuel in the sky
that's the real chemtrail you're we're
polluting the sky and we just love it
because we can get across the country in
in five hours and that's where guys like
Elon Musk and these geniuses that want
to create these incredible high-speed
trains that's what these guys are so
amazing because if they could figure out
how to do that and use the same sort of
technology that keeps Google cars safe
and if everybody can work together and
make these we might be able to change
the environment like the amount of jet
fuel that we burn there's like thousands
and thousands of flights every hour all
across the country constantly going back
and forth to the rocket ships apparently
take a lot of propulsion to get out
there's a credible network on the rocket
ships I talk to them and they're they
say oh yeah the the the biggest thing is
the pollution that's
created when the game's blast-off the
amount of whatever goes course fairly
well do it look you see fire yeah you
know nobody sees fire unless something
that's not good is on fire you know if
fires coming out of a metal tube that's
never good it's never waited for the
girl is that people have that
opportunity to investigate information
that's why right now I think that you
know in ignorant sand negligence or sort
of the same thing they're like people
say oh I didn't know well you don't know
because you didn't care enough to look
into it and that is true but sometimes
you get caught in a situation where you
don't you know you just still don't
understand even after all the facts are
in well you you also have contrary
opinions that are varied especially when
it comes to like certain historical
events like there's a lot of people that
want to talk about like JFK is a good
example it's a lot of people that love
talking about conspiracies they like
sure wrap that one up tight and when you
have these conversations with them and
you look at the the contrary evidence on
both sides pro and con it's like wow
there's a lot of like massive amounts of
confusion as to what the actual events
were but actually so many people wanted
him dad that you can't even pit the pit
you couldn't pin the tail on that donkey
no matter what yeah there was he had
multiple people that were upset with his
action boy would they be so lucky if it
was just a lone nut yeah these are so
lucky all those other people would be so
might be so lucky because then this
situation would have perpetuated to this
point now if it was a lone nut back then
and the system was actually failsafe
from situations like this I think with
in the 1960s in the death of Kennedy and
you know the Kent State shootings and
all that stuff I mean as tragic as it is
for then and for those times I think
that ultimately that kind of stuff is
sort of a reminder in a lot of ways to
the people of today about how bad it can
get if things get out of hand so when
they start creeping up on these
infringement on civil liberties like and
people start rising up that's where you
see things like us going to Syria gets
shot down I mean you see the entire
country both Republican that was the
first time that ever happened where they
had made a plan to go in and invade
something and they did not do it because
of the voice of the of the public the
voice of the whole public you know it's
like how many awesome a public
at this point in time or time I don't
care if you got a blue suit a green suit
a perfect piece no thank you
we're broke and we're not invading other
car what for what exactly we're not
fixing the problems that we have at home
how about the fact there's no water how
about the fact that Texas it hasn't
rained in Texas in fucking years you
know California had like one rain all
like over the past like three or four
months it's terrible this is I mean
that's something to consider this is
something to think about where the fuck
we're gonna get our water from
desalination plants maybe drain out that
fucking goofy ocean tire those fish
sucking up all the good water what's
happening with the fish all dead off
over there too everywhere what's going
on that's a lot of times is deal a side
effect of pollution too or it could be a
side effect of certain types of like
fish need a certain oxygen level and
things can happen and they develop dead
zones in the water and there's no oxygen
and all the fish just drowned you've
seen that on yeah yeah Julian some of
them the hundreds of thousands here
there we looked all over the world it
seems like there's problems but it could
be just you know whatever I don't know
well I think it's always happened but it
happens certainly because of pollution
as well I believe absolution is bad we
don't need to say oh look yeah it's okay
because it's only this amount or we get
we got a we got a can we are containing
it see this the containment system so
what do they do with that stuff stuff in
the ground waiting for Godzilla to come
what is that all about we're gonna
collect this garbage and then plant it
in the ground over here well that's what
a little kid does you know when you
sweeping up he just it's a cartoon you
pick up the carpet and you sweep it
under the carpet and you plot that
carpet down with no shit you know yeah
it's very childish way but it's also the
people that were alive that implemented
these systems I mean they're not alive
anymore and they were the when they were
our age it was a completely different
era and then when you go back to look at
their you know the distance between us
in the 1940s go back and look at the the
1940s and the distance between them and
the same amount of time and you're in
the 1800s okay you're in the like the
times where he were riding horses and
they had to paint their pictures that's
that's how much distance has traveled I
mean we really
if you go back to 1940 and you look at
those guys that are running the space
program or look those guys are involved
a nuclear program well how old were they
in their 40s let's say they're in their
40s let's say that they were born in the
year 1900 and they were designing and
working on all these these crazy
technological innovations from the time
if you went back from them to as far as
us looking at the 1940s you would be
what 60 74 years is it go tonight so 74
years before that yes 74 years before
that is 18 fucking 26 that is crazy they
got a horse that stop and think about
that there 1940 like world to us like
when we consider the 1940 world is the
early 1800s to them it's essentially two
decades or two cents on the just that
you know the the regular ratio mm-hmm
and you start to consider that what you
know the exponential type situation oh
yeah
their growth is uh you know defied as it
goes on it continues to expand itself
out no doubt I mean the growth and
change between 1820 and 1940 was nothing
compared to 1940 to 2010 I mean it's
just this this is mad more then it look
ahead and you say oh boy yeah I know
it's gonna be really weird but it's just
so strange that we are still running on
the momentum of these people's ideas as
far as like storage of nuclear weapon
off storages nuclear waste
reset yeah reset but that's nating no
reason kids in I agree wholeheartedly
but also as a person who's not involved
in creating nuclear technology not
involved in a that I find it fascinating
just as an observer like looking at it
all like wow this is really an
interesting scenario because it was
created by these incredible geniuses
that lived as long ago as 1820 something
to them I mean that is really hard to
believe it's really hard to believe
what's hard to believe is that we're
still operating on that same mechanism
to believe and it's it's hard to believe
that we still have like garbage dumps we
have like dumps like what I could have
dumps we take all the garbage we throw
it over there and then those dump lair
I started fucking disasters we went to a
garbage dump we film something for the
man show what a garbage dump once it was
what it was horrible
it was horrible fucking disgust where do
they dig a hole and dump the throw all
the shit there and stay just keep
digging holes it fucking stinks dude
they just cover it up with dirt and it's
disgusting doesn't like the fume the
methane or whatever build-up if you put
it under the ground that's a good
question I don't know I don't know I
mean methane comes from biological
weight as long as that this guy took a
rat a mouse and he made an art thing and
he covered up the mouse with the with
the resin right and then the mouse was
is he's running through the resin
apparently and tell it it couldn't go no
further right
he was like stuck in the resin the mouse
was that's an art piece that's an
asshole glued a mouse so it's inside of
this thing now and then there were in
the one day that was up on the it
exploded that was like made out of a
plastic glass stuff yeah and it exploded
from the GAT that the mouse was
off-gassing from inside of it and the
mouse created so much gas it blew this
whole thing up all over the place the
guy told me whoa
from the mouse being stuck in there the
gas that it was off gassing as it died
you know
you know the smelly smell mm-hmm he said
the house smelled like that - would you
therefore that I forgot who was telling
me no but somebody was in and they had
to come and do the mop down on the house
and everything but that seems like an
unnecessary experiment you got to
remember that next time you affect
messing around some mice don't stick
them in some plastic you know they don't
do well well this plastics is they can
make from plant material something a lot
of people aren't aware of you can make
plastic from hemp yeah yeah it's a
biodegradable plastic you can make from
hemp that's forgery right yeah yeah Ford
made the first car the fenders are made
out of hemp and you could hit it with a
hammer hemp is a where's plan ever you
know I'm not I know I sound like a
hippie when I start talking great about
marijuana but forget about marijuana the
the psychoactive benefits of marijuana
I've gone too in-depth I think there's
there's a real benefit to people and I
know I hear people saying oh you know
kids and what about the kids what about
kids what about the kids with fucking
anything kids can die from aspirin kids
can die if they have a contest to see
who eats more salt kids can die doing a
lot of fucking shit you know it's not
about kids
it's about responsible use of adults if
it's your kid you have a obligation to
educate your children do the best you
can to protect them from the dangers of
this world all drugs are a part of that
including hundreds of legal ones that
are available right now that can kill
your children so that's not the issue
marijuana is a minor minor minor issue
when it comes to health and safety
it's a major issue when it comes to
consciousness and maybe even more so
when it comes to the implementation of
hemp as a commodity hemp for paper hemp
for building materials hemp for
automobile panels that are lighter and
more durable Henry Ford figured that
shit out at the turn of the 19th or the
20th century I mean he was doing that in
the early 1900s this guy had figured
that out we see the the pants they make
out of it shirts and everything and
they're durable they're way more durable
than cotton and now that also has one of
the best root systems so they they what
they need to do what would it be good
idea to do is where you have these
erosion problems if they plant weed in
there the the routing system happy
obviously hemp yeah well to say we they
think your hipping you wanna get high oh
you know that's just you know you just
get in your own safety of your house
yeah this other stuff you could put
outside and let it grow and well hemp is
a very strange plant there's really no
plant like it on earth and it's
incredibly hard and dense but very light
as well seeds they they make that
omega-3 and omega-6 and well the protein
to hemp protein is the most easily
digestible protein salad add on it we
sell heavy hemp protein supplement we
bought the best hemp you can get it's
really fine it's very high in protein
it's the most expensive but it's the
best and a lot of people don't like the
taste I think it tastes delicious but I
always fix it up with coconut water I
just throw a banana coconut water and
hemp force into a blender and that's how
I am yeah you're off to the races it's
are just easy the thing about like I
like a
different protein powders but I feel
like the vegetable proteins I like pea
protein there's a Vega that is a I think
it's an all vegan based protein powder
all plant-based protein powder I like to
I like that I like those because they
digest very easily you're getting the
impact from yeah yeah I think it's it's
also it's very easy on the body whereas
I feel like whey protein which is also
very effective but it's made from in a
way which is made from milk products
it's it doesn't doesn't quite digest as
easily filled feel like makes my fart
stink here to everybody knees II my body
has no problem digesting it you know and
it's illegal to grow in America
unbelievable so stupid when I was a kid
I said my mommy said my mom hey what is
wrong with this stuff and she said oh
well it's illegal and that was the best
thing I could come up with that's not
even
well that doesn't even work with hemp
because hemp can't get you high yeah
it's the point I was worried about the
other growing but growing hemp is like
growing pine trees was like what if
someone came along and said he can track
all pine trees no more pine trees you
can't make pine tables you can't make
pine bed stands you know no more pine
you Billy what are you talking about I
can't grow pine or roses listen crazy
grow a rosebush kind of stuff out but
the the preposterous nests of pine is a
good one because it's so readily
available
well if marijuana was legal it could be
as readily available as pine trees the
shit grows everywhere if fuckin grows
everywhere and for the past hundred
years almost there's been this
ridiculous boycott on this magical plant
it's a magical plant if it didn't exist
and someone told you about it from
another planet we would be sending
spaceships out to get it if there was if
we found that there was pot growing on
the moon and they found that if the
astronauts went to the moon and they
came back with a plant and over the next
decade they analyzed this plant and
found it to have a million different
uses psychoactive ly medically to treat
PTSD inter ocular pressure from fucking
glaucoma to give people their appetite
back or they're going through chemo but
you go through a laundry list of
benefits of this fucking alien plant had
they do that fucking what's that virgin
guy Richard Branson he's be scented
space ships out to the moon with farmers
they'd have Mexicans in space flying
to the moon to harvest the marijuana and
bring it back home that's where we got
it here yeah we got it here and these
cunts are trying to keep it illegal it's
amazing dummies like that chris christie
dummy i don't understand it well i
understand I don't dummies they write
they rail against it they rail they
rallied scream that's why corporate guys
that what we need to do is have them on
the right side so you need to get high
they need to just chill down and say
listen hey okay we're gonna do it we can
do to make things better yes
and get on board and then people say hey
and the best ways for you to get high
you better grab them yeah sell that
stuff don't grab a cat say listen we use
it in our product now we use this stuff
because we found it's better than what
we used to use well I think there's a
lot of things that could be done to make
people overall just overall in this
country just a wee bit healthier just a
little bit of a change in the dial in
the direction that we're all going like
remember Anthony Robbins who although
I've made fun of inspirational guys I
think is actually a very inspirational
guy I think Anthony Robbins has some
really good advice and I've read a bunch
of different things that he said and
back when I was competing in my martial
arts days I actually benefited very much
from a lot of his he had audiobooks I
listened to by the pool when I listened
lived in a shitty apartment and one of
the things he said was that if he would
take any consideration like two cars
that are going in a certain direction if
one of them just has a very slight
variation off the line
just a slight over the course of time
the distance that it goes from the
original direction that was going to is
vast just a small change just a small
adjustment and I think that could be
said not just of cars that are driving
parallel to each other but of a culture
and I think that if something like the
tank came along and the tank in
conjunction with this newfound refusal
to accept the marijuana laws there's a
newfound refusal and now Colorado there
was a an article that was written that
came out today that I think it came out
today I found out about it today i
retweeted it today from reset me which
is our friend amber Lyons website and
essentially it's it's talking about how
Colorado has made more money and had
less crime and
taxes to six months read about the
school yeah the given point nine million
or something for the school system the
woman who wrote it
her name is Laura Pegram and yeah it
came out on the 27th so the school yeah
can you imagine that they're doing
something on the planet that's putting
money into schools and if you have a
problem with this and it's empowering
people start their own business the
right people people who are into wheat
they're gonna start their own businesses
and get rich that'll be a weird thing
when weed farmers are like a bunch of
rich people running around funding
schools weed farmers are paying for the
police to have better facilities weed
farmers are paying for the fire
department to be better equipped weed
farmers are paying for the teachers to
make more money like this is all it's
not just a pipe dream very with the
community and the officials in the
community to create a situation these
guys could be major influences on the
entire not only this part right in the
podcast people that are listening who
are not into we look that's it
that's it I'm fuckin hanging up
indoctrination even if you don't want to
smoke weed how could you ever say that a
hundred million dollars in cash revenue
100 million dollars is not a great thing
that you get that kind of taxes from
your first year and who knows where this
is gonna go could easily double by the
second year so then you got two hundred
million dollars in tax revenue oh my
goodness and they focus where it went
how much of the tax that you paid last
month went to the school system who
knows how much did the school get to
Colorado care about it Joe's not that
big no I mean it's it's it's big but
it's not like the amount of people as
California right not even close so you
spread that money out yes if you gotta
there's 800 kids and they made a
thousand dollars or whatever do you know
how much money marijuana would make in
California if they just sent it loose
just set it loose just Unleashed it
fully legal let's go I mean just the the
medical industry here is so gigantic
that there's businesses where doctors
just give people weed prescriptions it's
all they do it's all they do they have a
line of people with headaches out there
that's their business everybody's paying
40 bucks and they're keeping it moving
and that's legal I mean it's what
they've done legally is crazy if they
made it fully legal if they just said
release the hounds
it would change the culture it really
would and it would it would help a lot
of people would help a lot of people
that are resisting it it would help a
lot of athletes and the big one that
would help a lot of athletes is edible
edible marijuana for inflammation for
injuries for relaxation for stretching
just for your body just forget about the
you know psychoactive effects of
introspection and you know self analysis
and all that other stuff that comes with
the eating it the really the there's a
physical benefit so it would be pretty
substantial nutritional benefits mm-hmm
there's the nutritive you already talked
about that
you can eat it it's really good super
healthy great for your skin hemp oil is
good for your skin you cook with it it's
crazy it's just yeah you run a car on it
you could run a car to the oil the whole
thing is so ridiculous that if you
looked at it on paper and it wasn't the
case hey we have this stuff we just
figured it out today
it's called slippery whatever and we
have it well it'd be the great it would
be a great plot for a book if there was
a company that somehow another managed
to plot against one of the most
beneficial plants on earth and suppress
the development and use of it for almost
a century if that if that was a book you
would like be like captivated by this
plot like could this happen because it's
possible the one of the most beneficial
plants ever known to man could be
stifled they might have known about it
in the beginning
and then cut it off like say uh-oh this
stuff could catch on III think that what
happens is one of the things that
happens is when anything is illegal and
then you start arresting people for that
thing you make a business and I'm
arresting people for that thing you make
a business out of that thing being
illegal and then like we were talking
about before when those guys are out of
a job
like they're just out of a job so
they'll fight to keep their fucking job
and one of the best ways to keep your
jobs keep more things illegal right if
you're a guy who arrests people for shit
you want to make sure that more things
like marijuana stay illegal because
especially the DEA what would they could
do if marijuana became legal and then
people would start have to have to start
considering all sorts of other drugs
becoming legal as well maybe they could
figure out how to direct like the uh you
know the business aspects of it just to
take this money now and we'll have a
agency let's say that works directly
with these people that then you know
maybe then they could have a place in in
being helpful you know yeah I mean
obviously folks we're not this is not
something that we thought on in advance
we're trying to work this shit out on
the fly yeah it's not the best way to
design a government but it might be
better than what's already in place
you know what's already in place is just
fucking silly you can't tell people they
can't have weed stop it you can't you
can't tell it's not very nice to devolve
yourself in other people's business like
that they're not involved in yours
especially if you're ignorant you know I
uh when I was first starting to work for
the UFC I would often encounter these
articles that were written that were
critical of mixed martial arts and I
could tell by reading the article that
the person who was writing it had no
idea what they were talking about they
didn't understand the sport like from a
fundamental level they were incorrect
about the rules they were incorrect
about what was allowed
they were incorrect about the size of
the participants that there were one
size against all you know they didn't
know they were they were acting on
really old information really bad
information but yet here they are
writing for some having an opinion well
in writing it in a published form where
they spreading it out to the world
that's what they're doing when it comes
to slicing appreciation it's like having
a guy do a wine a wine review this never
had any wine yeah well I'll do you one
better anybody that is trying to get
anything like marijuana or mushrooms or
any of these things removed from the
culture and has no experience in them
whatsoever is like a guy who's never had
sex trying to make sex illegal it's mean
it's quele it's insane it's nothing
saying than anybody allows it if someone
who has never had sex before tried to
make sex illegal to all of us that enjoy
sex
you'd be like are you crazy it's like
one of my favorite things like why would
you cut the sex out because I don't get
sex so you don't get sex I don't like it
I don't appreciate it it rots your brain
it weakens your knees and someone could
just somehow or another trick people and
it not having sex
obviously sex is a natural urge
marijuana is something that you learn
about but they're both beneficial and
enjoyable aspects of this beautiful
thing called life and for whatever
fucking reason we've allowed these
dummies that are obviously like you look
at a guy like Newt Gingrich dude you
don't you know you don't get to tell me
anything you don't get to tell me what
to do or how to live at all you don't
get to I don't believe in you you know I
think you're a corporate puppet and you
don't get to tell me that pots bad
finally Chris Christie you're 300 pounds
you don't get to give advice you don't
get to give advice Oh
marijuana rots the brain in this what
about your fucking brain that's allowed
you to balloon up like another animal
you don't even look like a human you
look like some sloth some some walrus
type creature that's waddled out of the
ocean and put on big pants you're a
ridiculous person you can't talk about
marijuana you don't experience it if you
don't experience it on a regular basis
you don't know what the fuck you're
talking about and that's the problem
that we have in our culture we have
these people that are giving advice on
something that they have no exploring
other countries
we're over mixed-up in other
civilization these people they are
operating for thousands or hundreds or
whatever it is exactly and we're gonna
come over there said hey here we are now
we're gonna tell you guys what we need
humility from people that are leading
that's a very important thing so when
someone takes a big strong stance on
something that they don't have
experience with or they don't have full
knowledge of like to see was talking
about some study that they've come out
with it marijuana affects the brain yeah
it affects the brain but they don't know
what if it's good or bad did you read
that part of it they don't understand
what the effects are what the negative
effects are but here's other than
short-term memory loss no one's
demonstrated anything really bad but a
lot of positive shit too more shrinkage
all sorts of medical benefits that do
with deal with inflammation and
relieving of pressure and for a lot of
people it should Shermer you got so held
up on your I hate that forget it it's
over let it go short memory I like that
I got some details there later they come
up with me when I need them but it's
just isn't a Kerry garbage Iran you're
some father knows best shit is what it
is I mean we're watching Leave It to
Beaver we just
watching a less less like ridiculous
form of it more modern person incorrect
moral value on you they've decided what
is right what's wrong without having
enough information to even have a valid
effective what the gall of a man to say
that another man should not be able to
legally buy something as innocuous as
marijuana is so enraging who the fuck
are you can't smoke a joint somewhere by
yourself especially a person who placate
themselves obviously you're not you
you're not some militant fucking like
the the Gunny and full-metal-jacket mean
placate I don't know that word oh well
plate what's the best way to describe
placate like to make someone believe in
acid pretend like you're that way no no
to try to here I'll give you a perk to
make someone less angry I think it's
based on Placid oh ok - try to calm me
down right right right right right sorry
I lost my train of thought no no I'm
sorry I have a limited vocabulary in
certain areas but you don't though you
you have a very high technological
vocabulary I like to ask questions so
now I have that word in my repertoire as
well so placate placate the masses you
know that expression you've heard that
expression a common acid I think I've
heard the word yet never really
understood what was I saying now what
was I saying about the people and no oh
that he placates his body he can't he
obviously he gives in to his urges in
order to you mean he's in order to be
that big you have to be indulgent I mean
there's no way so he's got issues so
anybody that's got like some obvious
issue like that like man you're not
allowed to dictate health and and and in
like consumption power behavior yeah
yours is poor yeah it's ridiculous
control on yourself it's also against
the current data like there's there's
there's no like real consensus that
shows any sort of significant dangers
involved in the consumption of that
plant certainly not like some of these
other ones that have how many dead this
year from but you know what those other
ones are fine too I don't have a problem
neither being around but after part you
up there you get crazy with it you you
know you're you're
you're your own architect you know a lot
of people die every year from aspirin
aspirin kills people you know nobody
wants to think about that but people can
die from a lot of dumb shit that doesn't
make any sense it's available everywhere
it's not our issue is education and
honesty and if you're not honest about
something as innocuous as marijuana then
why am I going to trust you about
anything else like what we're where's
the dangerous shit no oh you were
keeping that legal because it's always
been legal well I'm not saying you
should make that illegal but you got to
let the less dangerous shit into yeah
this is and what if the less dangerous
shit changes the way people look at
everything including the dangerous shit
right and that's that's a real
possibility that psychedelics offer to a
lot of people that are addicted to
diseases a lot of people that have PTSD
they're addicted to diseases have
extreme benefits from psychedelics it's
legal crash you know see that's like I
told you in the beginning that's what my
mommy said all right so what does that
mean yeah I don't even understand what
I'm ranting too much I just get upset
and I apologize anybody's heard this
before
but I can't help it at certain point I'm
just it it hits me and I'm so confused
by it I feel like I need to repeat it
because it's so it's such it's the worst
part of where we're at it's a bottleneck
it's one of the worst parts is this lack
of understanding about what should and
shouldn't be happening to us whether
it's our government committing to Wars
or whether it's the people's emails
being spied upon or whether it's people
being forced to not consume certain
things that would offer different
perspectives or people being morality
yeah people people telling you what you
can and can't do that's not hurting
anybody else and I think one of the
things that I'm attracted to is altering
the the current way that I think and
altering the current way that other
people think and again giving you a
perspective of of the paths that we just
get on we get stuck in these fucking
grooves and it's so easy to keep making
those same turns over and over again
whenever you hit these very similar
moments in your life and that's where
something like the the isolation tank is
so good it's so good to just get out of
that groove I can't you know I think you
know like a log is even when I
you and everything like that you know I
I think I would know if I just gotten
back from Costa Rica or somewhere I
wanted I thought you know this is never
gonna happen
it says people are never gonna get with
this and then because it was just you
kept trying and now but now it seems as
if these people in general have gotten
up to a place where they're more willing
to experience themselves and then make
action on that yeah I think I think
where people are waking up with a lot of
things
I mean think what you were talking about
earlier about Pilates and yoga I think
people are just waking up about their
body people are really concerned about
where their food is coming from now this
is something that hadn't really existed
decades ago no one was concerned about
organics or you know when one was
current concerned about GMOs product in
general this is affected I don't and I'm
not necessarily saying that GMOs were
all bad because I don't think they are I
think there's definitely some benefits
to some genetically modified organisms
but I think it's important that we have
the conversations that people who are
really intelligent start dedicating time
and effort to researching jeff's and its
pros and cons and then relaying that
information back to the people relaying
it back to the public so we know what
we're in for
but then money gets involved in those
things and that's what people are
concerned about and that's the outcome
and then what you see you don't even
know if it was the yeah but it also
snaps people back and makes them more
involved in growing their own food and
more interested in organic gardens and
you've seen a lot of farmers markets
that are popping up left and right I
think farmers markets are amazing you go
there you get a direct connection with
the guy who actually grows the food this
is the woman who actually milks these
cows this is the guy that actually picks
this celery he's right there this is
their their special tomatoes they have
heirloom tomatoes you get to meet these
people you know I think that is that
that sort of connection is exciting to
people and that's the blowback away from
a lot of the other stuff but it's all
because we're getting this information
we're good and we're we're able to make
decisions kind of appealing yeah maybe
years ago you really don't want to meet
the farmer you don't know carrots tomato
came from yeah now it's kind of like
more interesting to understand you know
the the orientation you know how it's
happening or you know what's going on
people are more like this spray on them
they're out up then like I said if you
know people back there just stuff just
happened and they really weren't you
know I don't know if they were certain
they were just caught up in whatever was
going stuff it's cuz they didn't have a
way of communicating about it like we
have to the Internet really someone yeah
someone could put up a blog about here's
the dangers of this particular pesticide
on your tomatoes and then you hear about
that and you go wow that that is not
good and that's real the pesticides kill
bugs monitor kill bugs cuz they're
fuckin poison why why those plants not
getting poisoned well they are but just
not enough to kill him they figured out
a way to make a puppet one day and I'm
in there and a guy was in there spraying
the stuff you know I said don't my say
hey wisss conventional grown or
organically grown what what what does
that mean he goes well he goes uh I
guess if it's organic it's done without
poison and I said huh alright so the
conventional means is that a poisonous
substance in order to okay let's find
out about that because I've always
wanted to know what is the official
description what is the official
definition of organic please say I got
this from the clean food and I thought I
he doesn't seem to be a scientist but
that seems to make a lot of sense let's
look into Wikipedia this is organic
foods are produced using methods of
organic farming currently requires
countries require producers to obtain
special certification in order to market
food as organic within their borders the
context of these regulations organic
food is food produced in a way that
complies with Organic Standards they
keep saying nothing here
what's organic do we go back called
organic again while the organic standard
is defined differently in different
jurisdictions oh okay in general organic
farming responds to site-specific
farming and crop conditions by
integrating cultural biological and
mechanical practices that foster cycling
of resources promote ecological balance
and concern biodiversity I didn't know
that okay synthetic pesticides and
chemical fertilizers are not allowed
although certain organically approved
pesticides may be used under limited
conditions in general organic foods are
not processed use
irradiation industrial solvents or
chemical food additives I didn't know
the first part though I didn't know it
was defined by cycling the conditions
cycling of resources that's what they
need to do no shame yeah yeah the
nutrients mm-hmm in the soil there yeah
that's that's one of the most difficult
things about rotation I guess is a crop
rotation and also you know when you have
enormous chunks of land that are just
dedicated entirely to corn or entirely
to this or entire to that you know a lot
of times those farm lands become
minerally deficient and they have to
actually add minerals to the ground in
order to I think they would use in the
old days like they would use like fish
and stuff like that to try to replenish
their garden fish is apparently really
good for that but uh yeah the the idea
that that's a weird thing to want
something to be organic gonna you got to
ask for that it's like how did you allow
people to pour poison on food how did
you allow people to grow I mean isn't
there another way to deal with those
bugs can you like hire someone to clean
the bugs off and you have to fucking
spray death from the sky it sounds
ridiculous like my my version of it
sounds ridiculous birds and animals do
birds eat all the corn too though don't
they I don't know animals well you know
I was watching some show the other day
on the History Channel it was actually
about history which is hilarious because
you watch the fucking History Channel
was the last time you saw some shit
about history all right never it's
always like alligator farmers or
something fucked up but it was about
locusts it was all about the early 1800s
and these people were like traveling
across the United States
setting up farms and stuff and the
locusts hit these people's farms and
they had to send in the army to bring
these people food I mean these these
grasshoppers these locusts were just
they filled the sky for hours like for
hours and hours they filled the sky and
just flew by and just destroyed
everything just tore through people's
crops and they were talking about how
big it must have been the millions and
millions of bugs that must have been in
the air yeah they've been saying for the
corn though they went straight for crops
they just buzzed through and killed
everything they said you would see it as
a storm
coming at you and then as you look down
or looked up rather you would realize
somewhere along the line that that
wasn't a cloud that was a storm hola
pull up video of locusts pull up some
locust video from the you know you got a
clicky sound when it's flying I don't
know I never been around locust
I've been around grasshoppers apparently
they're in the grasshopper fan yeah
versus locust shells that's disgusting
you just like go outside you and just
see this empty shell of what looks
exactly like a locust oh yeah just the
outside of those things but if you've um
if you've ever heard of like biblical
predictions la kiss wasn't involved in
biblical predictions of a caliph to
conditions you know they always talked
about locust locust taking the sky yeah
like when you think about like old
horror movies you know like the demonic
possession things a plague of locusts
hit Egypt this weekend
causing some citizens to burn tires in
an attempt to ward them off that's when
you know shit gets ugly burn tires burn
tires swarm of locusts were spotted in
several districts of Cairo on Saturday
as they invaded the Giza area of the
Middle Eastern nation
oh let's see this shit I can't wait it's
like a previous from moving what is it
Star Wars bitch thirty million in sex
once upon a time in a galaxy far far
away let's see this shit I want to see
them invade I don't see shit there they
are that's it oh they're coming it's not
gonna be pretty
this is not good film this is terrible
I guess we're not seeing it in good HD
that's what it is
we're seeing in this shitty YouTube
thing via our television but yeah Wow
Wow that's a lot of goddamn bugs there's
the noise too
whoa that's so weird
they're like the ultimate gang and they
fly in this huge formation and just
caused massive destruction and
apparently they've done it you know
since the beginning of time occasionally
get together that's one of the things
that one of the signs gay people have
been fucking each other whoa look at
that
this isn't the congos I would have said
whoa look at that oh my god people are
freaking the fuck up bitch shut your
mouth Jesus Christ how old's that kid
she's over eight total shut her hole oh
[Music]
my god this kid with the ears shut this
kid down you know what I might be
screaming like a bitch all right I'll be
right there with the kid on a motorcycle
just trying to get home here just like
splat spots and this said the Congo this
is in the Congo so many of them this
mommy's not helping you dude what's she
gonna do goddamn storm you should be so
psyched that people invented cars that's
how you should feel right now you'd be
like people are awesome what are the
cars we invented to protect us from
locusts that's you should be thinking
should be like oh that's amazing
thank God the invested pesticides to
sprayed to the sky and knocked those
fuckers dead can they um do anything
when when locusts come do you think can
they like throw Nets up or anything
we're yeah what is it how do they stop
locusts you know you do you get like a
windmill with like a very large paddle
and you just put in the center of the
town just swatter just smack them right
in the face as they come in
just kill them all eventually put a
pretty sheet down below so when you chop
them up that's a good protein powder
there it's very good for your kiss
protein powder a lot of people eat bugs
in other parts of the other parts of the
world where they have to and the tasty
little pissed
yeah crunchy you know of you actually
eat them Wow know that what are you
saying crash thick doggone rock candies
yeah I never got a cha cha grasshoppers
really Jade them no I'd never tried it
but they you sell that shit at Urban
Outfitters actually Urban Outfitters
sells locusts yeah they sell like these
weird bugs that you just get chocolate
there I've had chocolate ants shattered
pillars the the thing about chocolate
answers you know they're actually good
for you like ants are actually good for
you like if as long as you're not poison
ants when you're eating ants actually a
good source of protein so it was a good
source of protein covered in chocolate
you kind of feel like man I'm not really
eating candy are you still eating candy
I think we put the windmill up after
they hit the the cornfield then after
all full of corn then we then we make
them into the powder and then they have
more nutritional value well I think even
if you put the windmill up you'd only
kill the ones that are near the windmill
the ones underneath the windmill that
are like your height in my height its
they fly like an inch off the ground
those fuckers like they're everywhere
kamikazes yeah there's so many of them
there's no room they can't all just be
in the sky does that happen how do they
all get born that's a good question I
think they fuck this all of those at one
time it's like I do
it's another clusterfuck the biblical
clusterfuck yeah wow we're lucky we're
very lucky especially here in California
we don't even have mosquitoes dude you
know I thought about that when I was up
in Canada we have to they have a thing
called thermos L you ever heard of a
thermos L it's weird it's like got a
compartment in it that you put like a
chemical and then you turn these suckers
on and then you put it down and this
like mist comes out and you can't smell
it at all but the mosquitoes avoid you
like the plague
so we would sit down outside in the
woods and it was really mosquito ridden
like immediately the mosquitos come near
and you're like holy shit I don't think
I could do this like this is rough I
think were all of you
you put this thermos elf thing down boom
10 minutes later they're gone before
that I got like a mask on ski mask and a
hat I got fucking gloves on I'm like
cheese and they're trying to bite me
through my glove like you fuckers
they're everywhere
this is the thermos I'll you keep it on
for 10 minutes there's no mosquitoes
boom no it sucks is those I don't know
if they haven't been in Los Angeles is
the Japanese beetles that in the Midwest
we used to get so many Japanese beetles
that would have to have these bags that
you put in your front and back yard
where the beetles will come in and get
collected in there you know just like
every week you just have this humongous
bag of just sweaty bugs we're trapping
right now yeah it's like a butyl uh
hotel yeah it's like a beetle trap just
wines and beetles Wow I saw some video
the other day of another thing we don't
have to deal with there was a hailstorm
somewhere that it fucked this guy's car
up this guy's entire car was like
covered in like dents like everywhere as
if it had like a really bad case of
chickenpox and scraped off all of its
scabs like the whole car was just popped
in windows are broken the list the hail
was so big it shattered the windshield
was one of those hits you in the head
father's your dad many people died from
hail over here more than Hill City lot
10 more than coconuts for real I don't
know I know some people do they say they
died from coconuts look how excited I
got 150 people die every year from
coconuts really yep okay how many people
died for a year about hail how many
would you say died before I left for
California my house got the golf sized
hail went in a hole Columbus area and
everybody's car got ruined everybody's
house was ruined people would moved to
Columbus just to be insurance agents for
like a year because everyone's house
were fucked and so everyone got new cars
like it was so weird that like the whole
city almost got new cars at the same
time oh my god there's a hail storm a
hail stone in 1928 that weighed 1.5
pounds what is it how big is that it is
7 inches Wow
it weighed 1.5 pounds and it came from
the fucking sky it's believed to be the
largest known in the u.s. at the time
and they captured that bad boy huh seven
inches oh okay there's another one that
in 1970 that was one point six seven
pounds so it was even bigger Jesus
Christ a Labor Day thunderstorm costs
342 million dollars worth of insurance
damage in Calgary oh he's out there
looking for the bigger one yeah oh no
sorry that was eight twelve ounces over
there you know no no here's a bigger one
you know somebody's running around in
the there's this ice balls flying around
the place every now and then you know I
can calm it on Kansas had this one in
1992 two batches of severe thunderstorms
for six hours
Oh within six hours of his I dumped
hailstones up to four and a half inches
across this area including the city of
Wichita surrounding counties of
south-central Kansas and over ten
thousand homes were damaged the hail
left wheat fields and a near total loss
property damage told 500 million dollars
with crop damage at a hundred million
people died though I can't find it
I can't find imagine if you'd be the
first dummy that died from hail stay in
when that stuff they say nobody dies not
okay fuckin you're fine
you know stalk a wheat doesn't hurt that
bad let's see hailstorm
I tried to get hailstorm Fred the
fatalities as many people die a year
from hail twenty seven people died from
tomato tornadoes and hail storms in the
Midwest
what's that says here nine hundred
people a year what's how many say it's
from the coconut again what'd you say
150 150 where does it say that 900 a
year where does it say that it just came
up how many people died from hail nine
hundred a year it can be very dangerous
thing okay any instances of death
there's only one here that says they
know of of in the United States 1939 in
Lubbock Texas a farmer got caught in an
open field and died from hail yeah
death Fort Collins an infant lying in
its mother's arms was killed by hail
1979 can you imagine that it doesn't
seem like ya laughter you do Matt if
you're caught an open field and it
started coming down hard it kills your
kid oh that's got to be there's not many
people man I don't believe it's 902
years yeah this actually says the last
known death was caused by hail and the
US was in the year 2000 yeah that makes
sense there was 900 total well you know
what today people know so much about
storms and if you live in an area where
you might you know you live in some
Kansas type area where they have hail
storms on a regular basis we get it yeah
look at the car is getting pummeled you
know hurricanes are way scarier
hurricanes are the most scary you ever
showed this old house yeah I remember
yeah Bob Vila and they still have that
show on I watched some PBS this weekend
and they were rebuilding the Jersey
Shore and they were showing how I mean
it's destroyed it's destroyed but so but
they've had to do is go under all these
houses and like lift them up all 10 feet
so all the houses are going up 10 feet
to make them taller make them tall so if
the water comes in again they're okay
right and they have to take these
humongous like like like these like
holes you know they look like telephone
poles and if they'd like push them into
the ground like 20 feet or something
like I just know it made it such a pain
in the ass and it's not gonna be they
say
Jersey Shore is probably gonna come back
for another seven to ten years
completely until it's back to normal
that's incredible yeah I can't believe
that they're gonna do that and make
these poles and then just sit there and
what if the water is I'm actually
fucking sit in your house and the water
comes up to the top of the pole yeah and
you're like oh my God why did I build a
house here again what am I crazy yeah I
got the ocean under my now right I hoped
I put the boat on the roof see the ocean
like slowly coming up closer and closer
to the bottom of your house oh you just
got 20 feet why would you go over that's
20 feet you have to get all the way up
there and the shit would be swaying the
breeze you'd have to dig deeper holes
for the columns you'd have to worry
about me I don't know how strong the
ground is there we had a house in Hawaii
it was on poles it was a race to beat
you got washed away in 69 Wow
houses the the waves came up so high is
it between pipeline and why maybe they
live in sunset there was a there's three
houses there on poles because they had
been washed up on the cam highway when
they brought him back down they put him
up on these poles and we lived in one of
them wow that's pretty cool but there's
waves never came up that high I mean I
think they're only counting on tsunamis
and shit I think that's what that pole
thing yeah but a tsunami the thing is if
the water comes in it's not coming in by
itself okay did you ever watch the
tsunami that hit in Japan yes it's
bringing in boats and houses your house
is gonna get hit by a boat yeah you
don't want that to happen man we want to
get out of there just fucking count on
that ten-foot pole that's fuckin yeah
there's people that stayed in you know
many storms I remember Gloria when I was
a kid when I was a kid and I lived in
Boston is when a hurricane Gloria hit I
want to say boy if I had to guess I'd
have to say I was in high school so say
was in the 80s it but uh it was a huge
one and it hit way to fuck up the East
Coast and it put knocked the power out
in a lot of places okay
doo doo doo doo doo it was 1985 so it
was when I was in high school and I was
graduating that wasn't like my senior
year of high school was 85 and that's
when this fucker hit and it hit the
first major storm to affect New York and
Long Island directly since Hurricane
Donna in 1960 so people went a long time
they went 25 years when they hadn't had
a hurricane hit him and this
motherfucker came down and wiped out
everything and power was out and I lived
in Boston which is pretty far away from
the epicenter of the storm but I
remember it being utterly humbling I
remember we were in my house we were
looking out the window and the trees
were just fucking like they were like
like leaves they were blowing back and
forth like they were just leaves like
there was no weight to them and he would
you would go out afterwards and just
trees would be falling everywhere just
collapsed over streets collapsed on
houses collapsed on cars just broke
trees everywhere and just the feeling
like whoa like you know I had been in
storms before I'd been thunderstorms
before I'd been in snow storms before
but there was something about a
hurricane and even a hurricane that you
know I was way away from the center I
lived in Boston I lived in Newton
Massachusetts actually so that was like
you know a suburb of Boston like man we
didn't you know we didn't always yeah
just the residual off incredible I mean
it was I couldn't imagine what it would
be like to be in one of those Katrina
ones the ocean is so powerful that that
water you know when I was out there I
started learning out surf to about the
same time near-death I don't know how
many time you hit by one of these waves
ya know that the water possesses so much
power you know you you really have to
have a respect for it you know once it
gets riled up like that coming at ya
there's not a whole lot gonna be done to
slow it down I don't think well I think
we're basing our ideas about what the
atmosphere is like like what the
weather's like what the you know the
safety of being around volcanoes the
safety of being around the ocean we're
basing it on the few hundred years of
people have been paying attention and
taking notes you know how many people
have been here before that the Native
Americans only really what happened to
them
yeah well that was us most of it but it
was a tsunami area but there was
certainly people that died in that way
as well you know we just didn't hear
about it I mean they had to be people if
people have lived in North America for
the past you know X amount of thousands
of years like they have evidence that
goes way back to ten thousand years ago
of people living in North America so if
that's the case for sure or something
during that time like there had have
been a bunch of events a bunch of things
happening we just we're not aware so
when something like Katrina comes or
something like Gloria comes when I was
in high school like you you go where is
this part this this can happen to like
this can fuckin happen like shouldn't we
be preparing for this how often is this
happen well the last time it happens
1960s I just relaxed okay but it can
happen right this can happen you should
prepare for this now that you know that
this can happen
there should be no houses that are built
from here on out they can't deal with
this because it might not happen but it
could fuckin happen it has happened it
you've got two of them on record you
one from 1960 you got one from 1985 what
the fuck do I have to tell you we're
waited for that these bitches are
happening they're coming let's get ready
you don't know what could happen you get
three of them in a year like the ones
that existed before people measured
things they still existed the giant
fucking storms had killed people before
meteorologists were invented we're still
valid and this idea that we're basing it
off on this tiny little window that
we've been alive you know I'm fucking
I've been in LA since 94 I haven't seen
a single fucking significant earthquake
does not worry if everybody's a pussy
are you crazy
this fucking thing's on a piece of
moving ground it's just you don't live
long enough for it to move that much
because the the perspective it's kind of
high you're looking at in terms of a
human life perspective you got to look
at in the fractal sense there's no
guarantees yeah this years is nothing it
could be right now it's time to be up
was just think about what we were
talking about before the difference
between us and the people in the 1940s
the difference between the people in
1940's and the difference between them
and the people in the 1820s add all that
stuff up together look at it and just go
back a few times like that a few
generations like that and that's what we
have that's the amount of information we
have it in not that time in those time
periods we have a bunch of them we have
the earthquake and fire in San Francisco
we have floods we have Hurricane Katrina
we have Gloria we have the the most
recent ones the the tornadoes that that
one that fucking town in what was that
town that Joplin Mississippi like almost
completely wiped off the map I believe
it was Joplin I should probably say rear
Mississippi Missouri yeah you're right
you're right you're right Joplin
Missouri my favorite places are you
really hang out in Joplin all the
tornado they joking joking bro yeah 2011
in Joplin a tornado struck Joplin
Missouri
it was a large a larger late-may tornado
outbreak and it reached a maximum with
ready for this of one mile a width of a
mile a tornado that's a mile no no no no
no no
no that's the devastation path Oh mile
wide when it comes through the terror 5
it isn't I don't know I don't know what
that means no it means death yeah it
reached a maximum width of nearly 1 mile
during its path through the southern
part of the city it rapidly intensified
and tracked eastward through across the
city and then continued eastward across
interstate 44 into rural sections of
Jasper County and Newton County it was
the 3rd tornado to strike Joplin since
May of 1971 the tornado killed 158
people with the additional four indirect
deaths injured some 1,150 others and
caused damages amounting to 2.8 billion
dollars it was the deadliest tornado to
strike the United States since the 1947
tornadoes whoa since the turn in 47
there was a multiple yeah sure the
glacier higgins Woodward tornadoes in
1947 yeah and these they traveled 125
miles from Texas to Oklahoma destroying
everything in its path because it was
originally thought to have left a two
hundred twenty mile path but it's now
believed have been a part of a family of
eight or nine tornadoes a fuckin family
of tornadoes these tornadoes although
deadly did not match the astounding
death toll of the earlier event nor did
they match the record speed of that
tornado or the although at over 40 miles
per hour they qualified as a
fast-tracking storm Wow dude could you
fucking imagine looking out your window
and seeing nine tornadoes coming at you
and just thinking about all the times
you jerked off and what the Bible told
you and you're like thinking it was you
you know if you lived in 1947 there
locust are coming on top of it they know
it's over if you were in Texas and it
was 1947 you could convince yourself
those tornadoes were coming for you
because you jerked off if you were 16 if
you were some kid who's just resisting
Church so bad but you couldn't you
couldn't stop beating off and still go
to church you dad would scream at you
and you're in there beating off and you
look out the window and you see 9:20 and
you're fucking convinced it was you
convinced it was you that killed
everybody fire and brimstone Brian
Redman masturbating the devil has sent
his henchmen to take you out of the path
and out of the path of righteousness and
you have to become a priest because
everyone in the town died cuz you you
and you're beating off you fuck family a
tornado's yeah that's a terrifying idea
there's a lot of heavy vibes on that man
you know you're behind a mile-wide
tornado what the hell man I know them
that little patch I wonder if I could
score NATO's I'm wondering I'm correct
saying the mile of destruction because
it sounded so much better than just the
actual width of the storm it's so happy
we don't have to deal with tornadoes man
that shit was I saw one the other duck I
saw one the other day where I saw a
tornado of leaves oh yeah out of nowhere
yeah that's true
weirdest shit ever I mean it wasn't
tornado The Kills obviously I was
driving and I stopped my car to watch it
yeah crazy you ever gone through like
the desert like like like driving like
Vegas or something you'll just see on
the side of red like a a sand tornado
you're like what the fuck is that is
that gonna hurt me Yeah right like um
they can get them I mean they have
gotten them in California before we look
that up one day what is it anyway some
sort of a weather condition something
else and it starts to spinning I believe
it's like cold weather mixing with warm
water it's like cold France and warm
warm weather there's just been just I
don't know I don't know okay let's look
it up this is like a cyclone - you're
the cyclone learn today we're learning
every day hopefully well I'm not gonna
go along with that I'm it's more sexy
black helicopters a tornado is a
violently rotating column of air that is
in contact with both the surface of the
earth and a okay ready for this one whoa
how do you say this q CU m UL o n i m bu
s q come come you lon
bus camel anima bus come cumin Kuya
cumulonimbus
cumulonimbus whom you lo Nimbus cloud or
in rare cases a the base of a cumulus
cloud and they are often cumulus they
were often referred to as twisters or
cyclones although the word cyclone is
used in meteorology in a wider sense to
name any clothes low-pressure
circulation tornadoes come in many
shapes and sizes but they're typically
in the form of a visible condensation
funnel whose narrow end touches the
earth and it's often encircled by a
cloud of debris and dust have you ever
seen the video from Dallas Texas from
two years ago where semis were flying
through the air surrounding a twister
pull that up pull up semis flying
through the air in Dallas twister it was
the craziest shit I was watching on TV I
was in Texas at the time - I was in
another part of Texas and they oh wait a
minute that's not sure now I was in
Texas during another one but it wasn't
this one the one where they had it on
the news I think I was in another state
but I could have been in Texas I was
like I was on the road I was like I
could've been in Texas right now I've
been there for Texas anyway point being
I'm watching the news and here it is
this is exactly the footage and there's
a Twitter twister this is on the fucking
news and the guys talking and you see
actual semi like tractor trailers flying
through the fucking air like paper cups
man like as you're seeing this this
funnel spinning look at that see that oh
those are tractor trailers man and look
they get a we log in look at you see the
things crackle see all the electrical
fires because they were there removing
them they're removing electrical cables
and shit from the ground and shorting
things out and eventually it picks up
these tractor trailers and is they're
flying through the fucking air is this
the same video I believe it is ok there
there's one flying through the fucking
air look at that that's a tractor
trailer bro it's flying what is that way
what
but it's gotta weigh a few thousand
pounds well it depends if it's got
anything in it - yeah but if it does
even if it doesn't have anything in it
well there's one yeah that's flying
through the air and landing on shit
boom it's throwing it through the air
those are all like cargo boxes and
tractor trailers it's great look at all
those tractor trailers just jacked
picked up and tossed and twist it around
like like an aluminum foil amazing they
landed near the highway it's fucking
crazy other nature's uh that bitch
doesn't play no it's on her terms
yeah it is on our terms especially when
we're fucking around light and shit on
fire and sending rocket ships into space
fucking with the air airplanes burning
fuel and cars or burn fuel and add into
the pollution yeah it's weird but even
if we didn't even if we didn't add that
even if we did in the places goddamn
horrifying mess even if we didn't do a
goddamn thing if we lived our lives
completely eco-centric if we lived our
lives with organic farming if we lived
our lives in a completely harmonious way
with nature we could still get smushed
by a big Robert bass clobbers boom yeah
not to say that we shouldn't be you know
loving to our mother earth and we
absolutely should absolutely 100%
without a doubt no argument from me but
it's possible for us to get fucked up by
a supervolcano even if we did even if we
did an ice age can come even if we did
the best we could do
well the dinosaurs are all died yeah
with meteor no they were using their
cell phones too much your my cell itself
a fucking cell phone
drew in Madrid they found old cell
phones that dinosaurs used and we
realized these were super fucking smart
that cell phone data picture that guy on
that line who's in the beginning of a
movie and he was walking borrow the
phone on his ear was a front of man's
theatre what was that movie there was a
lost clip they found off of an old movie
Charlie Chaplin movie
oh no no no yeah they had a he had a a
eat that's what everyone thought I saw
that guy walking yeah that's not what it
was there was an invention that they had
come up with for people that were hard
of hearing before they had hearing aids
and you hold it up to your ear
and magnify the sound that's what it was
and so to in a blurry image when you're
looking at it you know yeah it's like a
future guys on a cell phone well you
know to this day people have ear
problems and they they get hearing aids
you see them a lot they stick out of
their ear
well back in those days they just held
it up to their ear right right that was
a sound yeah I just saw that sound
amplifier yeah you wonder yeah if
someone's gonna do time travel I don't
think they would go to Charlie Chaplin
days yeah already gonna hang around here
and do that for could you imagine if we
did find out that some dudes been
fucking travelling back in time from the
future and we get up to the future one
day we meet him you're like wait a
minute dick I've seen you before
find out he's Jimi Hendrix he's fucking
there's been a bunch of different people
like he's just been going back in time
and being a bad motherfucker but really
just some guy from the future you never
know you know there's no you do know
that's ridiculous and I'm stoned
I don't you never know I'm hoping
Hendrix shows back up then I think
listen it was already here I got a
Hendrix shirt on man poster here that's
a cat that left a uh you know something
behind that he was awesome but he
doesn't need to come back yeah now you
got Gary Clark jr. and I'm not saying
Gary Clark jr. is equivalent to Hendrix
but I'm saying look there's always going
to be honey honey there's always gonna
be you know new bands that come out
there's always gonna be like cool let's
home sounds is the Black Keys there's
always going to be you know there's
always cool shit man it's always coming
out I'm glad fuck yeah this is the best
time ever
I agree anybody doesn't think this is
the best time ever on earth is silly
you know taking advantage of the
situation then yeah here's what we have
we're here all this stuff to keep us
happy and keep us occupied calculator
watches you know cell phones tons of you
know things that occupy our time and
there are things that occupy our time in
a negative way they can they can take
your time away but they also give you
the opportunity to do things it's up to
you to decide what you do with your time
exactly that's that thing again is it so
they say oh it's bad to be selfish and I
think oh it's not because if you're
concerned with yourself and what you're
up to
you turn out to be a better product for
the other people around you you said oh
wow this guy's actually spend some time
with himself yeah some fish is a weird
word though because when I think it's
selfish I think of like you know I read
II like you know you know those movies
where like people are trapped somewhere
and it turns out one dudes been hogging
all the food and lying about it yeah
that's guys it's selfish fuck that's the
way they present right yes you know I
mean you hear about that guy you like it
you dick or one guy like shuts the door
you know like stop don't shut the door
hmm
that guy's selfish right that's a
selfish person then you hear the people
get killed by the monster all right and
you find out that he shut the door you
like you dick that's a selfish guy but
there's also self-aware and
self-awareness and concentrating on
yourself and some people are
uncomfortable with other people
concentrating on themselves
some people are uh they're uncomfortable
with people that are like really into
their bodies they're uncomfortable the
people that are really into fitness are
people that are really into health they
get they get upset at them they don't
like it it makes them feel bad
we remember these to look at the label
in the store and you look at these
people in this in a shopping store and
they're looking at the label and what
are they these are words you don't even
know what they mean and you know many
years ago mm-hmm everybody's now looking
at it high fructose corn syrup look at
that time to change can't tell you how
many times I've greedy intent say it I'm
not gonna eat it you know I can't even
read what this stuff is I'm not gonna
put it in my mouth I mean you're kidding
me you know and I started looking at
recently and I never looked at before
grams of sugar and drinks like grams of
sugar in like like a sports drink one of
those sports drinks type things it's
crazy so it's like more sugar than
you're supposed to have in a day well is
it sugar even now this one's are from
the beets and there's this stuff from
the corn beet sugar you know they sure
yeah it sounds good well you know it's
good I think that they're supposed to
have been modified or something I don't
know chemtrails yeah tried not to get
too upset by all this but try do you
like it when you buy the sugar get the
cane sugar organic cane is it yeah
that's what the labels now that I
understand that I don't really your body
doesn't want sugar like that I mean you
can have it in cookies and you can have
it in cakes and you can have it in
moderation and you'll be fine but your
body doesn't want
your body wants sugar that's attached to
foods yeah there's a lot of yummy stuff
that oranges didn't exist okay if they
didn't exist and he had to go to some
plays crazy exotic location to find an
orange like a real good ripe Florida
orange when those big plump ones but
it's easy to peel and he bite in and
that's fuckin like also delicious it
would be an extreme luxury it's so much
better than caviar it's just caviar is
hard to get but caviar tastes like dog
shit it's grow oh it's an acquired taste
no one needs an acquired taste for
Elijah's oranges are delicious
oranges are you like caviar yeah I used
to live with some Russian people and I
got a you acquired the taste I did
acquire the taste but it is I can
appreciate the it's nothing wrong with
it but my point is the owner why I am
Ryan jizz right there perfect it's
delicious it's very different I get it
it's a sophisticated palate that
recognizes recognizes the subtleties of
our caviar caviar is from a very
particular type of sturgeon yeah I can't
even tell fit to create I mean if it's a
black or the red or whatever is it it's
all taste kind of like the same to me
it's dog shit it's like wine nasty I
never used to you know like I can't
really tell the difference oh this is a
taste like a wine you know I can taste
good wine like wine it tastes good I
just don't it's good Assam all yay that
is a real job like someone who actually
understands it while it the guys are
really good at it they really is really
is an art just weird it out and stuff
they don't even swallow it otherwise
they'd get fucked they could tell what
it is by swirling and somehow in their
mouth a yeah well that you still get
drunk but you get drunk less quick than
if you drink at all yeah you know it
tastes good
and your tongue some wiggle your yeah
some of them a drink it though they just
go old school and get that fucking
horseman wells potbelly and keep rocking
and keep hitting Sonoma hard every year
fucking pound that that's an Ian Ayres
wine I never gone to one of those those
wine tasting points yes Ryan swear it's
great it's fine I don't to be around a
bunch of stinky drunks cultured wearing
your fucking boat shoes get away from me
dudes with those moccasins with the
fucking those weird yellow
shoelaces in their moccasins get out of
your mouth oh you're doing and yeah
exactly
those weird things I know what you're
doing do gigs down there at the Gainey
winery Gainey want you heard of that
gigs a band that you know it shows yeah
it gained a winery
they have gigs at a winery yeah yeah
outside it was like a party we're
running out of time so let's talk about
your your tank Center and the new place
that you guys are doing and what's the
difference between what you're doing and
what a lot of these commercial places
that are using these home tanks we have
there's a real problem with that right
as far as like infections and far as
safety and as far as like everything
needs to be moved to a higher standard
that's certainly our opinion of the
situation you know we've been working
with you know with NSF and the other
state and local authorities then to get
in tune with what's required as far as
rules and regulations as far as testing
the water and that's that's our
certification we've been certified for
that which I have a 3 log kill what they
call which a 99.9 of all the
microorganisms that are in fact they
infect the water then they see how long
it takes to eradicate this infection and
obviously this is a big difference
between someone who just has one that's
only for them only for their own
personal use which is like a lot of
these more low-end ones and someone who
is running a commercial business sort of
like the difference in your home pool in
swimming pool I always like to say you
know it's like you know opening a
restaurant with an easy-bake oven mm-hmm
you know it isn't appropriate right for
appropriate you see this is not up to us
to decide anyway all that we've had to
do is adhere to these standards and
codes that have been set up by realistic
people that understand and you've helped
with these these setting up these
standards outsole is a very important
thing for you super important it's more
important to us than anything else is
this disinfection this ability to
disinfect this water solution correctly
between usages because we don't use
chemicals and we're all tested you know
to do this 3 log we actually did a seven
log in a vessel the vessel itself
generally contaminates the specimen but
we have such a small body of water in
such an intense system there of cleaning
that they tested the
material in the vessel and we've still
got the three log and then surpassed
that but that's within one cleaning
cycle without in the use of chemicals
the problem with chemicals now which is
what everybody else has to do due to the
fact that they don't willing to spend
the money on the disinfection process
which is this I told you about this UV
lights like nine grand if seventy five
hundred for the generators and so
there's a lot of bread to get it right
man you know in the electrical stuff CR
ul listing as well underwriters
laboratory this is electricity and
people you're into a water and
electricity you can't you know say
scooter McGee said it's okay or shifty
Williams over here Williams yeah who are
these people and what it makes them
unlucky and shifty fucking shift he's
got as before you know and referred as a
story but the the facts are the facts
you need to go into a laboratory and
evaluate the situation correctly we
utilizing you know methods of their
ethical not not you know you pouring
this chemicals the chlorine and bromine
and procs whatever it is you're pointing
is a breaking down now this this is a
material and then creating a byproduct
this by-product then you know you're
getting in there with it and you're
sweating or pissing or spitting or
whatever then you're mixing you with
this you know the ammonia or nitrogen
that's what a lot of people have an
issue with when I talked to him about
the tank they always say that like I'm
gonna get in the water that someone else
has been in the bank and we're they
should have an issue with it there is an
issue with it it is a you know if these
things are not dealt with properly
they're you know it's an infestation and
as the popularity these things grows
this is something we really need to
consider because this is something that
could become an issue for some folks and
I know that you're very conscientious
about this is very important to you and
this is like one of the main focuses of
conversation that we've had over the
years is about this this need to make
sure that everything is like at the same
standards of the tanks that you have
it's supported for the people that are
doing this to have a product then that
is credible that has been designed
correctly that's had a lot of time and
effort spent to to verify how it
actually works of what it does you know
and then does all the horror all the
good and none of the harm right and
that's
all the potential harm are all checked
out and no undocumented and and and in
like I said this is new and ul stuff to
the amount of you know adjustments that
we've had to do with the electrical
aspects of this thing are tremendous you
know but it by the time we've been
working with him what now four years
with NSF to try to establish these
guidelines then for you know effective
purification yes for people then to do
this because if you don't have it and
people come away from it with a bad you
know how long is it gonna last
right the industry you know it needs to
have guidelines and standards set up to
adhere to then to become a credible you
know industry well I commend the fact
also that your your your immediate
head-on before it becomes a big issue
like there's not a lot of people that
are reporting like infections and one a
lot of people that have become sick
because of it no but is if this industry
continues to grow the potential
instances of people not taking care of
their water can rise and that could
potentially damage their the reputation
that you fought so hard to try to let
people know about the positive benefits
of this me I know you you've been
working on this for a long time and it's
catching on now right yeah it's you know
it's it's it's been something I've been
dedicated to with you know all of my
everything I have you know it's been
involved in trying to get this right
because it's it's important you know
that that this technology is not
overlooked right now we need to get a
whole you see if it if it's set up with
these little Mickey Mouse second-rate
rigs the authorities are not going to
okay and they're not going to allow it
we've already been but they allow it
right now but now it's unregulated okay
so it's going to eventually be ran out
so that's what this right but I know but
to people that are listening when is
this all going to take place it's
happening now we we have a task group
that's been formed with both the
Canadian Ministry of Health and several
health and safety officials here in this
country state wise local wise and NSF
national sanitization foundation to set
up these guidelines so they're realizing
that this industry growing the inner
steppin in absolutely absolutely we were
at a
a task group what was a thing called the
we went to a thing and they had callers
calling in it was the most asked about
subject a topic that they had conversate
about at this it was called a task what
was the meeting call do you think that
it's possible for you to make two
different tanks to make a commercial
fully sanitize unit and make a unit for
the home that's less complex and more
affordable we see we were thinking about
that because naturally that would be a
good business sense but we got back to
the point again it's like in order to do
it right
this is what it costs I mean we could
make it Mickey Mouse or whatever but is
it Mickey Mouse for the consumer like
say if it's just you a crash lives by
himself crash loves to do the isolation
tank you battled a jerk-off or pee in
his tank or if I do I'll be in there
with myself yeah I mean it's like yeah
but if you're going into someplace and
it's these people in those pits not you
know right but it what's happening then
what we were doing was trying to you
know people they're cheap so there goes
first of all people are broke two rows
also fucking super expensive to buy ones
atoms that's correct
I know that the the equipment is really
costly and it's really high-end but all
I'm trying to say is with our last five
minutes of time folks are into a pumpkin
all I'm trying to say is is it possible
that it's it could be made into a
consumer unit yes it would be but back
to the liability see in order to get
this right and not harm anybody by this
can you know different things it's it's
it's not easy like how much more do you
have to say about this stuff do you want
to do another hour wanna shut this off
and do another hour you know be cool to
talk about this are you running out of
gas I'm not running out of gas I don't
run out of gas okay let's just wrap this
up because this we're running that time
yeah we'll wrap this up we'll be right
back in about ten more minutes so I have
nine minutes that's an extra fine man
we'll wrap it up we'll wrap it up and
come right back alright so thanks to on
it comm go to onn I T use the code word
Rogan and save 10% off any and all
supplements I just want to give us give
you a chance to go into a lot of these
issues that
talked about before so we'll be right
back with crash it probably won't be a
full podcast but it'll probably be like
40 minutes that's what I recommend I
recommend another 40 minutes I'll be
right back
[Music]